Musik 1,2, 1,2, ich laufe jetzt schon. Also was ich natürlich versuche, ist in einer einigermaßen natürliche Haltung zu geraten, damit wir hier ein Gespräch führen, was man uns auch abnimmt und nicht nur eins, sondern wir sprechen direkt ins Mikro rein. Ja, aufrecht. Und ja, ich versuche aber trotzdem mal ein Nahmikro zu sein. Es ist so natürlich, dass ich hier so einen Riesen-Pop-Schuss vor dem Mikro, ich will dein Gesicht gar wir gegen die Wartentreffen, ja, es ist so natürlich. Also die Leute kennen ja primär deine Stimme, deswegen ist es jetzt ein bisschen schwer, dich zu verorten visuell. Aber dein Kopf ist wirklich kreisrund und passt genau auf diesen Popschuss, das heißt Stefan sieht wirklich nur die Ohren, links und rechts. Das sind nur die Ohren. Wahrscheinlich das schönste, was man jemals immer gesagt hat. Wo wir gerade bei Vergleichen sind und Geometrie, du klingst wie Jörg Thaddeus, ist dir das schon gesagt worden? Das ist so passbar. Ich weiss, permanent sagen dir Leute irgendwas, du siehst aus wie, du hörst dich an wie, ja das ist wirklich, heute wieder zwei Leute haben gesagt, du siehst aus wie, was war es heute nochmal, Stein, Alligator. Also Oppenhövel, das habe ich ja jetzt von Mommisch gehört, aber du klingst wie Jörg Thaddeos. Du bist ja die jüngere von euch beiden, ne?
Ich bin die jüngere, ich bin die wesentlich jüngere, ich bin zehn Jahre jünger. Aber man kann sich tatsächlich fragen, ab wie vielen Leuten, mit denen man verglichen wird, wird es zu einer Beleidigung, weil irgendwann hat man einfach keine Persönlichkeit mehr. Ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen Stefans Problem. Ne, Problem, naja, Max Biermann, keine grandiose, hat man gesehen jetzt Sketch History, der ist in Kinski geschlüpft, kann auch noch andere Sachen, die ich jetzt, ja, hätte er vorher aufschreiben können, aber er kann sehr gute Sachen machen, weil er einfach so aussieht wie viele Leute. Oh, das ist, das ist der Grund, das ist seine größte Qualität, auszusehen wie viele Leute. Ich will gerade in die Situation schön reden, dass ich aussehe wie viele Leute. Ja, dein Gesicht ist eine Leinwand und es gibt gute Leinwände und es gibt halt auch die Strecke. Mein Gesicht ist wie ein Blatt Papier und ich es füllen. Warte mal ganz kurz, ich merke schon, das Gespräch ist scheisse bis jetzt. Lass uns mal ganz kurz... Oh Gott, so gross ist die Dose. Das ist die King-Size-Dose. Ein Liter Booster. Trinkt er da zusammen draus? Den haben wir tatsächlich nie benutzt. Ist das so eine Art Freundschaftstest oder? Ein bisschen, ja, den haben wir tatsächlich nie benutzt und heute darf ich nicht mehr öffnen gehen. Also es ist der Ein-Liter-Booster, es hat was sehr Fallisches. Führe mal um und ich versuche dabei nah am Mikro zu bleiben. Es hat was sehr Fallisches, es ist ein riesiger Lustprängel, würde ich sagen, der Boost-Your-Mail-Insecurities-Booster. Ja, ich habe mir mal den Booster Absolute Zero aufgemacht. Da riecht es. Und ich habe einen kleinen Salat, vielleicht bin ich ein paar mehr. Ich habe mir so einen kleinen, ich weiß nicht, also da schwimmen ja Schinkenwürfel drin. Also jetzt, ihr habt schon gehört, wir haben heute einen Gast, den Stefan. Stefan ist kommend hier. Herzlich willkommen. Steven Titsch ist heute bei uns zu Gast. Herzlich willkommen, fantastisch. Ne, es gibt ja tatsächlich ein paar Ungereimtheiten, was die Aussprache deines Namens angeht. Und da möchte ich jetzt einfach mal Klarheit schaffen. Es ist Ralpehe Ruthi, tatsächlich, der ist heute bei uns zu Gast. Herzlich willkommen. Vielen herzlichen Dank. Im Podcast Ufer ist natürlich Stephen Titschler
wie immer auch natürlich dabei, muss man nicht erwähnen.
Ist wahr, ich habe mit meinem Booster
Absolut Zero es eben untergegangen, aufgemacht.
Du erwähnest es bereits? Einfach mal so ein bisschen,
ich probiere das jetzt mal.
Ich glaube, wir hier ganz... Ja, lass uns abschliessen.
Ich glaube, es ist weniger Kalorien.
Hier kann man noch mal wenigstens hier eine Bar simulieren.
Prost. Ich glaube, es ist
maximal, es ist trotzdem maximal Energy, minimal Kalorien. Ich glaube, ich bin noch nie so erfrischt worden. Ja, guck mal auf die Nachwirkungen. Lass das mal auf die Wirkung. Ich glaube, das hier ist schon eine der Nachwirkungen, dass ich denke, ich sei hier. Aber wir haben ja heute einiges vor, wir müssen geboostet sein. Wir werden heute ein bisschen über deine, ich sag mal... Ganz kurz, wir müssen ganz kurz synchronisieren, so haben wir keine Chance, das Ebenen zusammenzubekommen. Wir müssen alle gleichzeitig klatschen. All the single müssen alle gleichzeitig klatschen wie wollen wir synchronisieren ich glaube du musst einmal reinklatschen jetzt in beide sehr gut das sind die Tricks wir brauchten 30 Folgen um zu merken dass wir Tricks brauchen um es zu synchronisieren wir haben manchmal so ein Phasing da drauf gehabt das ist richtig ja wir haben maximal Facing, wenn es diese Phasenverschiebungen gibt und das so leicht facet. Tu doch einmal so, als würdest du den Begriff kennen. Ja, wir wollen heute ein bisschen über deine, ich sag mal, skandalgetränkte Karriere reden. Ich hoffe, ihr habt den schmutzigsten Scheiss aus dem Bulli gezogen. Wir reichen ja schon wahnsinnig weit zurück. Also ich glaube, damals Frau Buschert, siebte Klasse war es oder sowas. Ja, aber zum einen hat sie mich provoziert, zum anderen war sie auch einfach eine Hotte-Gilf. Ja, ich weiß, aber ich glaube, da haben wir uns, was war das, achte Stunde oder sowas, du wegen diversen Bemerkungen, schmierigen Bemerkungen, ich wegen gefährlicher Jagd auf Mitschüler mittels Steinbrocken. Wir waren damals nachsitzen. Wie nannten wir uns? Wir waren die Roten Raben, glaube ich. Ich glaube, wenn man heute noch in den Schulraum gehen würde. Ihr wart die Roten Raben. Ich glaube, man würde heute noch auf der letzten Bank hinten links, war es neben... Na klar, da ist auch die Kerben noch alle in der Tischplatte, aber einfach um das Publikum zu verwirren, haben wir uns Katzengesichter gemalt. Und deswegen kriegen wir das nicht zusammen. Und wir haben Delfingeräusche gemacht. Warte, Delfingeräusche, Achtung. Das waren wir, die roten Raben. So sind wir immer durch die Schule gelaufen. Und machen wir uns jetzt vor, das Einzige, was von den rotenen Rahmen geblieben ist, sind die Initialen und daraus habe ich da meinen Künstlernamen abgeleitet. Und wie spricht man ihn aus? Rocco Beppo Zoppolini. Rocco Zippolini. Ich glaube, wenn man heute noch in die achte Klasse gehen würde, man würde immer noch die schmutzigen Cartoons sehen, die wir damals, die ich damals reingekratzt habe. Hast du auch, ne? Leuten mit diesem Tod und dann dieser Typ, der in der Wand wohnt, habe ich mir damals ausgedacht, und der sprechende Baum und alles, also das war für mich so eine kreative Frage, und ich glaube, da stand auch mein Name relativ deutlich unter diesen Entwürfen und als urheberrechtlicher Anspruch, glaube ich, würde das heute auch noch durchgehen, also ich will jetzt hier gar nichts sagen, ich sage nur, meine Karriere ist auf Sand gebaut, machen wir uns nichts vor, das Kartenhaus fällt in sich zusammen. Heute sind wir hier um das alles, also du gräbst eigentlich jetzt schon an meinem Fundament. Man muss ja sagen, dass du der perfekte Gast für den Podcast bist. Stefan, oder? Nee, er hat nur auf mich gezeigt, weil er mit meiner Anekdote vorweg greifen musste, meinen zurechtgelegten Witz. Ich wollte eigentlich nur sagen, dass du der maximal schlägteste Gast für ein Radio bist eigentlich, weil du nur visuell funktionierst. Dein ganzes Leben baut auf dem Visuell auf. Das hätte man nicht beleidigende Ausdrücken zu haben. Das stimmt ja einfach. Wir machen immer so eine Good Cop, Bad Cop Nummer. Aber in der Generalkugel hat es nicht ein bisschen Patsche geklommen. Also ich habe noch heute eine E-Mail bekommen von einer Mutter, die gefragt hat, ob ihre 15-jährige Tochter, hier lasse ich eine Kunstpause, einfach um euch, um die Fantasie schweifen zu lassen. Wird ein Mensch schweift? Auch wenn er es nur Mütter schreibt. Also ich bekomme relativ häufig Anfragen nach Schulpraktika, dass Leute bei mir quasi
das Zeichenhandwerk lernen können.
Und das ist einfach totaler Nonsens, weil ich weiß nichts darüber. Ich bin ein ganz, ganz schlechter Zeichner. Viele von euch werden das ähnlich sehen. Aber es dient dem, was ich erzählen möchte. Also ich kann das zeichnen, was ich möchte. Mir geht es um Mimik, Gestik, dass man erkennt, wie tickt die Figur jetzt, wie steht die anderen gegenüber und der Rest Fluchtpunkte setzen. Sowas interessiert mich nicht. Und wenn jetzt so eine Schülerpraktikante mal mehr gerne lernen möchte, wie sie das Zeichenhandwerk lernt. Dann weiss ich schon mehr als du. Auf jeden Fall, ich bin der denkbar schlechteste Ansprechpartner dafür, weil mir geht es nur um Humor. Tatsächlich ist das ja auch in meinem Bühnenprogramm so, dass man vieles auch einfach vorlesen oder nacherzählen kann oder in eine Geschichte verpacken. In Tweets verpacken ja ja manchmal mache ich da auch haue ich da einfach so ein Wanderer raus oder sowas weil mir gibt es noch Humor ja sehr gut uns nämlich auch ach komm aber da bist du glaube ich im falschen Raum gelassen eigentlich schade dass die ganze Folge die jetzt irgendwelche Grafikerfragen stellen wollten und Fluchtpunkte hat uns wahnsinnig interessiert also ein bisschen schade dass es uns jetzt noch mal die Farblehre wenn sie das malen können können sie auch das malen die Farbleh würde mich interessieren. CMYK? Bisschen der RGB oder CMYK-Typ. Ich habe vor allem jedenfalls gutes Farbsehen. Das macht man auch beim Führerschein. Ja, Farbsehen und Sehtests. Was ist deine Zweitlieblingsfarbe? Ocker. Auf jeden Fall Ocker. Mir geht es ja, also ich finde es ja toll, wie Bilder und Farben wirken können. Also unabhängig jetzt von der Botschaft hat es für mich immer so etwas ganz Unmittelbares. Also so ein Bild, das nimmt dich ja irgendwie ein. Also das ist ja noch vor jedem Verstehen und Perspektiven. Das ist immer so, hat für mich so etwas ganz Emotionales, Direktes, was mich irgendwie direkt persönlich an... Da kann man sich ja fast nicht wehren. Es ist ja fast eher anstrengend, sich gegen so ein Bild zu wehren, als wirklich darauf zuzugehen. Weh dich nicht, lass es zu, lass es rein. Ich versuche es zuzulassen, aber manchmal ist es auch für mich einfach zu stark. Der Chessbreaker unter den Kartonisten. Für mich ist es auch manchmal einfach zu stark und deswegen muss ich mich auch oft von deinen Sachen einfach kurz entfernen und zu sagen, oh, das magische auch. Mein Tritt zurückgehen, das Kunstwerk im Ganzen betrachten. Das war jetzt gerade eine Fantasiewelt. Also es ist jetzt nicht, ich bin mit diesen Figuren so eins geworden, es ist so, als würde ich sie schon ewig kennen. Für alle, die jetzt zugeschaltet haben, Florentins Eltern wissen vielleicht noch, wovon er spricht. Ja, die sind heute nicht ihr, wir können sie einfach mal. Das sind auch meine Eltern. Hallo, ich bin Florentins Vater. Nee, das sollten wir nicht machen. Das sind diese Einbahnstrassen, diese Hörspiele, die wir ab und zu machen. Aber Hörspiele ist ein guter Stichpunkt, denn du bist ja nicht nur für deine Cartoons bekannt, sondern auch für deine Synchronarbeit. Ich glaube, du machst ja die Windows-10-Fehlermeldung, oder was machst du genau? Er hat so wieder so ein Gag-Dokument zu euch gelegt, mit dem ich nicht klarkomme. Hab ich nicht! Du hast die ganzen Sachen, die du gerade aus... Die denkst du nicht gerade selber aus. Ich bin diese hilfreiche Büroklammer, ja. Ja, genau. Die wird gar nicht gesprochen, die hat ja nur diese Sprechblasen. Aber sie wurde gemalt. Nee, aber für die Blindenvariante des Betriebssystems. Blindenfussball ist ja auch ein großes Thema für dich. Hast du da nicht einen Gag zu? Komm, da hast du was im Petto. Haben wir da eigentlich nicht mehr gehört. Also, pass mal auf, Leute. Blinde Leute können auch Fußball spielen, und ich finde es echt scheiße, dass ihr euch darüber lustig macht, weil Behinderung, das Wort Behinderung existiert für mich nicht. In meinem Vokabular steht nach Behörde steht bei mir direkt Behilfswerk, ja, und Behinderung ist bei mir komplett raus, das gibt es nicht. Für mich hat jeder Mensch die gleiche Möglichkeit und jeder Mensch, der Fussball spielen möchte, darf auch Fussball spielen. Dafür setze ich mich auch für meine Stiftung ein, nicht jeden Tag, ab und zu. Ich glaube, ich habe jetzt in den letzten drei Jahren einmal bei der Versammlung, aber auch nur ganz kurz. Aber im Endeffekt ist es alles da, tatsächlich. Du engagierst dich ja tatsächlich, aber jetzt mal weg von allen Witzen hier, du engagierst dich ja tatsächlich viel für, was war es? Leute. Für Leute, genau. Es gibt ja wahnsinnig viele Leute, das ist ja oft so ein Ding, dass man denkt, also zum Beispiel habe ich bei deinem Cartoon gesehen, 2000 positive Bewertungen, da dachte ich, holla ho, da muss es ja, wenn man mal ein bisschen rechnet. Auf welchem wo? Auf rute.de, wo man alle deine Cartons angucken kann, deine Bücher kaufen kann, für deine Bücher wahrscheinlich Tickets buchen kann. Da habe ich gesehen, 2000 positive Bewertungen bei einem Cartoon, wo ich sagte jetzt, nja. Ist okay. Aber da dachte ich, wenn 2000 Leute den gut finden, hochgerechnet, muss es ja mindestens 400 Millionen Menschen geben. Ne, Moment. Wenn 2000 gut finden, finden es immer noch circa sechs Milliarden Scheiße. Also sechs Milliarden Menschen haben nicht aufgespielt, wenn du klickst. Du hast vollkommen recht. Warum, was macht das mit dir? Es ist tatsächlich so, dass ich manchmal inzwischen, also kommen wir mal auf den Boden der Tatsachen zurück. Ich finde es selbst ein bisschen irre, wie viele Leute mir eigentlich bei Facebook folgen. Da sind ja irgendwie jetzt, geht auf die 900.000 zu, bei Twitter sind es ein paar. Aber bei weitem doch nicht genug, Ruti. Und immer wenn ich denke, das ist echt ganz schön viel, steht ja dem gegenüber, dass einfach Millionen Menschen den Scheiß überhaupt nicht kennen. Ja. Und nicht mögen, sie hassen, es muss auch verpassen, dass sie es hassen. Ja, zu Recht, zu Recht, weil wir wissen, es ist Humor subjektiv und irgendjemand will das immer hassen. Aber es ist doch schön zu versuchen, mehr Leute zu reichnen. Ihr wollt ja letztendlich auch natürlich, dass ein paar Leute den Podcast hören, weil es einfach total unterhaltsame geile Scheiße ist.
Ja, aber ich denke mir manchmal, ich habe jetzt 35.000 aktive Twitter-Follower und ich stelle mir manchmal vor, wie diese Menschen alle auf der Erdkugel gleichzeitig klatschen. man würde es nicht hören, glaube ich. Und das irritiert mich so ein bisschen, ich würde es gerne hören, wenn alle meine Follower gleichzeitig oder gleichzeitig in die Luft springen, irgendwie so ein Erdbeben auslösen. Doch in Taiwan hat es maximale Probleme. Du hast wirklich sehr viele Fake-Follower, haben wir beide bekommen, weil du uns ja Fake-Follower gekauft hast. Das war kein Scheiss. Das war kein Scheiss. Und wir haben wirklich maximal Probleme. Ganz viele Leute in Taiwan oder so lieben uns. Wir reden uns an, dass sie unsere Tweets lieben.
Die hören einfach gerne Deutsch.
Ich glaub auch, und wenn alle die einmal springen würden,
dann gäb's hier keine Probleme, aber Taiwan.
Man muss tatsächlich sagen, wenn man unseren Podcast mit halber Geschwindigkeit anhört,
ist das sehr nah an dem nördlichen Kanto-taiwanesischen Dialekt.
Es ist vor allem sehr nah an Charlie Sheen zu seinen dunklen Zeiten,
wenn er gerade massive Drogenprobleme hat. Es klingt wirklich furchtbar, wir klingen wahnsinnig betrunken und irgendwie auch so ein bisschen breit. Macht ihr das auf halbe Geschwindigkeit hören? Uns haben jetzt zwei Hörer, haben uns was zusammengeschnitten. Können wir das einspielen irgendwann mal? Nein, das ist wirklich viel Arbeit, das einzuspielen. Naja, es geht. Naja, komm, da muss ich auf Knöpfe drücken und ah, keine Lust.
Jedenfalls haben die uns so einen Ausblick geschickt, wo die uns auf halber Geschwindigkeit
abgespielt haben.
Oh, das hören wir uns jetzt mal an.
Nein, auf keinen Fall.
Es ist wahnsinnig witzig.
Der Einspieler, der jetzt kommt, der nein, der jetzt kommt, Stefan, die Leute können das pausieren, die können auf Twitter gehen. Das macht doch kein Mensch, das Podcast-Ufo ist ein Lean-BBerg-Ufos, das können die nicht machen, die sitzen jetzt irgendwo am Baggersee und schlürfen in der Kaprielsonne. Was ist gerade passiert, was haben die Leute gerade gehört, was haben die gerade gesagt, wer ist zu Gast, Ralf Ruffy, muss ich mal gucken, Ralf Ruffy, mal gucken, wo der irgendwie unterwegs ist bei Twitter. Habt ihr eigentlich wirklich Fragen aufgeschrieben, ihr habt ja immer so, jetzt kommt ein spieler und ganz gut ist was gut ist ja genau Fazit gut ja hat ganz gut funktioniert das war das Das war einiges Mal, wo ich mir in meinem Studium richtig in ein Thema reingearbeitet habe und hat auch ganz gut funktioniert. Ein paar Gags natürlich eingebaut hier und da, die wurden nicht so ganz verstanden. Nee, die kommen wir nicht mehr an. Natürlich, das kann man nicht machen, aber ich habe einen sehr realitätsnahen Approach genommen und ich glaube, das kam ganz kurz ein. Eins Komma drei. Das ist natürlich. Das war schon lustig, oder? Wie das Klang bedeutet. Ich habe noch Fragen aufgeschrieben. Ja, ich möchte jetzt mit einer Frage anfangen. Und zwar folgende Fragen. Ich bin so gespannt, ob ich's wirklich reinschneide, damit wir uns ja dann sehen. Ich hab echt Fragen aufgeschrieben. Fühlst du dich von Sat.1 eingeschränkt? Steckst du in einer Unterhaltungsmaschinerie fest? Du hast in Kanada studiert, hast du mal Bock, Stand-Up auf Englisch zu machen? Alle Comedians haben ein Defizit, was ist deins, kann man auch dir stellen theoretisch. Idyllisches Familienleben, Karriere Wurzeln-Haken. Das ist alles noch Mockridge. Alles Mockridge, auf den habe ich mich maximal vorbereitet. Mockridge ist Rote-Fan übrigens, kein Scherz. Echt jetzt? Ja, bei sich. Hat er aber euch anders gesagt. Nein, ja gut. Puh, der hat Wörter erwähnt, die müssen wir hier piepen, du. Möchtest du eine Frage davon beantworten oder nicht? Das war, nö. Nee, dann habe ich euch anders gesagt. Nein, ja, gut. Der hat Wörter erwähnt, die müssen wir hier piepen, du.
Möchtest du eine Frage davon beantworten oder nicht? Das war, äh, nö.
Nee, dann habe ich noch eine Frage.
Du machst jetzt Cartoons und die sind ja oft, sag ich mal, humoristischer Natur.
Und ich habe mir die Frage gestellt, könntest du dir auch mal vorstellen, irgendwie was anderes zu machen?
Als Cartoons.
Todesanzeigen zum Beispiel.
Also das ist irgendwie mal, also damit...
Todesanzeigen habe ich gemacht, weil ich habe ja lange Zeit bei einer Tageszeitung gearbeitet und habe dort Anzeigen gestaltet und auch Familienanzeigen. Das heisst, liebe Käthe, schau mal hin, heute stehst du auch mal drin und in voll langer Trauer, das habe ich auch hin und wieder gemacht. Hast du auch eine lustige Cartoon-Sunde gemacht irgendwie? Nee, aber das Geile war, dass mir das viel Zeit liess, um nebenher auch schon mal Cartoons zu machen, weil das kam immer so Schub. Also wenn man bei einer Zeitung arbeitet, ist es halt so, da kann es mal sein, dass zwischen elf und drei gar nichts ist. Und damit einmal kommt der ganze Zinnober da rein und da habe ich schon Cartoons gemacht. Es war tatsächlich sehr lustig, als wir nach der Frank-Elster Masterclass unsere kleine Firma gegründet haben, waren wir auch in Räumen und wir waren direkt neben, weil da waren auch einige Zeitungen in dem Gebäude. Welche? Und da waren wir in Räumen direkt neben der Todesanzeigenannahme der BZ. Wie, die haben nur eine Anzeige von Todes? Ja, also der traurigste Raum der Welt und wir waren halt direkt daneben und unser Studio war daneben und wir haben halt jeden Tag irgendeinen Scheiss gesehen mit Windmaschinen und ,,Allo, hier kommt Ram Ram Ruffio", irgendwie brüllen da rum und lachen den ganzen Tag, wup wup, und da kamen jeden Tag Mails rein so, Leute, ihr könnt doch nicht an die Kontaktanzeigen, wenn hier die Witwer und Witwen stehen, hier so rumschreien. Und wir wurden tatsächlich langfristig, mussten wir da einfach raus, weil wir es nicht auf die Reihe gekommen haben, still zu sein, weil wir immer, boh, du traust dir nicht, das zu essen, Alter, ey, du, boah, und da drin. Ja, also er wurde dann mehrfach von einem Lkw überfahren und, boah, Alter, wenn du das jetzt kriegst, sind Euro, alle, boah, also den ganzen Tag halt irgend so ein Schein. Oh Gott, wie unangenehm. Das ist eine unangenehme Situation. Lass uns mal kurz auch eine unangenehme Situation überlegen. Ne, lass uns mal zusammen Cartoon malen. Oh, das funktioniert super. Super im Radio. Darf ich eigentlich Radio sagen? Ja, ist doch kurz so. Na ja, gut. Aber, Leute, zwangsläufig wollen wir gerne ins Radio. Also, liebe Radiosender, alle Leute, die uns gerade hören, ich finde es ja einfach total, warum bin ich eigentlich hier? Das ist doch einfach nur grossartig. Also alles baut auf dem tief schwelenden Hass von Flo und ihn gegenüber, erstmal meiner Person oder meiner Arbeit. Was heißt Hass? Das ist interessant. Kurz nochmal, um alle ins Bittnisboot zu holen, so moderativ hinter euch aufräumen. Wer betreut denn die Accounts, bist du das? Wir machen beides, wir schreiben beide darunter und irgendwann haben wir angefangen, uns selber observational zu beobachten. Genau so sagt man. Diese vierminütige Pause, die Sie gehört haben, war nicht eingespielt. Die ist tatsächlich so passiert. Sehr unangenehm. Und dann haben wir irgendwann angefangen zu sagen, was der andere von uns jeweils gerade gesagt hat. Und es fiel wirklich der Satz, ich hasse Rute, ich hasse ihn wirklich, der Kontext ist erstmal egal. Naja, war ich noch? Ich würde es super gerne wissen. Und dann fiel der Satz und dann habe ich ihn aufgeschrieben einfach mal. Aber jetzt nicht irgendwie in der Absicht, dass wir dich an so einen Haken ziehen, dass wir dich herausangeln aus dem Promi-Sumpf und irgendwann mal hier ins Podcast-Rofo setzen, sondern es war wirklich dann alles und hat seinen Lauf genommen, du hast es irgendwie gesehen. Und das fanden wir sehr lustig und dann hast du dich eigentlich selber selber ein Gedanken, weil es so sympathisch ist. Ja, es ist richtig. Also ich hatte keine Ahnung von der Existenz dieses Podcasts, ich ähm, das hören wir sehr oft. Sechs Milliarden Menschen noch nicht, ich wollte nochmal drauf, also ich kannte, ich kannte Florentin und das ist Zucker in den Popo, ich fand es super, was du machst, wobei ich meine Cartons, die ich in der neuen Klasse gemalt habe, die fand das ja ganz geil, oder? Ich fand dich als Performer ziemlich geil. Ah ja, okay. Wo denn? Natürlich erst mal den Biefträger und dann kamst du da raus und ich dachte, das ist ein geiler Typ. Und ich konnte noch gar nicht genau sagen, warum. Und dann habe ich aber auch so ein bisschen recherchiert und geguckt und eine... Also ich jemanden, der so Nummern macht wie, was war dieses Ding, wo du da rausgekommen bist und diese ganzen Politiker aufgezählt hast mit der Trommel vorm Bauch?
Ah ja, mein zweiter Ausrede im Niemagazin.
Meine Güte! Und das fand ich irgendwie schon...
Ich habe nicht weder geschrieben noch gemacht, ich habe es einfach nur gesagt.
Ich sage ja, ich finde dich als Performer, also du hast deine Präsenz...
Inhaltlich furchtbar, aber performance-mäßig.
Stefan, kannst du uns kurz allein lassen?
Ja, sorry, ich lege das raus.
Aber jedenfalls, dann wusste ich dich einzuordnen, von dir wusste ich leider nichts, habe dann so ein bisschen geguckt, hab dann geguckt, was ihr gemacht habt und hab dann diese Folge mit Nils Buckelberg so halb gehört und fand das total sympathisch, hab mich total an mich mit meinen Kumpels ändert gefühlt, wie wir halt irgendwie, also unter uns, wir haben als Kinder eben auch einfach eine Hörspielkassette reingelegt, mit Tape überklebt und dann haben wir selbst solche Sendungen aufgenommen.
Und bei euch hört es halt jemand, weil die es ins Netz stellt.
Ja, stimmt.
Es gab keine Netzwerke.
Das ist der große Vorteil unserer Generation.
Das stimmt. Und das fand ich aber großartig. Ich habe gedacht, da würde ich gerne sitzen.
Und ihr macht ja auch geilen Scheiss. Ich habe ja dann einfach natürlich einfach ein bisschen gegoogelt.
Und ja.
Also erstmal natürlich vielen Dank für das ganze Lob. Es freut mich sehr. ich finde auch, dass ich da oft sehr, sehr gute Arbeit leiste und tatsächlich muss ich sagen, dass ich auch tatsächlich auch so eine Show hatte als Kind, die Teenies, Geld, Krieg und Lachshow hieß die, also für Leute, die es nicht wissen, dass mein Spitzname früher oder bei engen Freunden auch heute noch Teenie ist tatsächlich, da gab es die TGKULS, die Teenies, Geld, Krieg und Lachshow. Ich hoffe, das führt irgendwo hin. Ich hoffe, ich auch. Das ist genau die Angst, die du gerade hast. Die habe ich jede Woche. Führt das irgendwo hin, was gerade passiert? Ja, unterstützt mich doch an, statt mich da in den Weg zu legen. Mach ich doch gerade. Nein, warte noch mal. Humor-Podcast. Und da musste man immer die alten Kassetten. Wir können ja auch mal ein bisschen in der Vergangenheit schwelgen. Wir sind ja hier auch ein bisschen 90er-Kids, wir sind ja beide aufgewachsen mit Saturday Night und Bam Boom Bang, Eighteens, whatever. Die roten Raben. Von Areola! Da musste man ja bei den Kassetten immer diese beiden Löcher mit Tesafilm zukleben. Wisst ihr noch, das ist eine Luke Mocketsch-Nummer, komm mal drauf. Wisst ihr noch, wisst ihr noch, nee, damals, als es die Turtle noch gab und dann haben wir immer die Fünf-Freunde-Kassetten aufgenommen. Aber das geile war, jetzt lass mich doch einfach mal ausreden, das Geile war bei uns, dass wir diese Sendung aufgenommen haben auf die alten Fünf-Freunde-Bibi-Bloxberg-Kassetten, allerdings haben die nicht so richtig aufgenommen, so nur so halb, das heisst, man hatte immer zwei Spuren, man hatte einmal die Teenage-Gelking-Lachshow, wo ich mich um Kopf und Kragen geredet habe und im Hintergrund immer Bibi, wir müssen aufpassen, die Pferde sind schon wieder entwischt, ja, also wenn der Euro dann jetzt kommt in drei Jahren, dann, oh, Baby, schnell, Hex, Hex, Zauber, und es war also wirklich eine Kackophonie an wirklichen Gassel. Man kann aber auch das einbinden, diese geile Geschichte, die Hintergrundläuft mit dem, was man gerade macht. Ja, man hörte das ja selbst nicht, das hast du hinterher gehört, wie so eine Aura lag das da ja rüber, also das war nicht wirklich was, was du selbst beim Einsprechen mitbekommst, sondern bei den ruhigen Stellen schimmerte das so durch. Wie Pergamentpapier war das da drübergelegt. Einfach so unangenehm.
Aber wenn es dann immer leiser wurde, wurde aus irgendeinem grundtechnischen Grund im Hintergrund immer lauter.
Und es war so eine Wellenbewegung und dann kamen Freunde und ich muss euch unbedingt diese geile Sendung aufzeigen.
Das ist furchtbar, ich kriege Gänsehaut. Ich meine es ernst, weil ich das total toll finde und mich das daran erinnert.
Und da sind wir bei diesem Gemeinschafts-Erinnerungsgefühl und du hast mich tatsächlich gerade abgeholt. Aber tatsächlich habe ich das alles noch. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das noch hast, aber das ist wirklich wahnsinnig wertvoll. Ich hab das alles noch, ich hab sechs Kassetten vorne und hinten bespielt, einige mit meinem Cousin und einigen meiner besten Freunden. Ich bin jetzt 19 und das war, 12, glaube ich. Also das ist wirklich schon eine ganze Weile her. Und das ist echt geil, das noch zu haben. Und ja, ich werde ein kleines Highlight-Reel schneiden und das hört ihr jetzt. Forget it! Not gonna happen, nope. Wird nicht versehen. Nein. Wollen wir vielleicht mal ein bisschen freestylen? Weil wir wollen... Oh Gott, wir spitten ein paar Rhymes. Also. Ehrlich jetzt? Mein Name ist Stefan, das fand ich nicht für Spaß. Das ist immer meine Leine und wir geben jetzt Gas. Ralf Rute ist hier in der Haus und ich glaube, ich bin jetzt raus. Hey, der rote Rahmen. Ich muss es mal rein. Nichts einzig aus Raben. Wir sind die gerobten Raben, wir haben die guten Gaben für alle euch, wir bringen euch in den Graben. Du kannst deine Skills begraben, die Bangehands und labern. Ganz kurz, kannst du uns mal zeichnen? Irgendwann mal. Punkt eins. Wenn du jetzt 20 Minuten brauchst, um uns zu malen. Nein, nein, nein, ihr seid ein Typ, euch Kiechen. Subtil, subtil und indirekt fragen, ob er uns zeichnet kann. Also ich sage ja das, was auch viele meiner Kollegen sagen, die Kartonisten sind, wir sind keine Karikaturisten. Wir können halt nur unsere Figuren und ich habe es am Anfang erwähnt, ich bin echt kein guter Zeichner und deswegen habe ich die Skills eigentlich nicht. Das kann jeder Pariser Strassenmauer besser. Aber man schaut ja schon mit einer richtig ordentlichen Verachtung auf Karikaturisten zu. Das ist ja die unterste Zunft des Künstlers, oder? Der Karikaturist. Das ist wie für einen Stand-Up-Comedian der Zauberer. Also erst kommen die Karikaturisten in diesem Sinne, dann kommt Ralph Hute, dann kommt Lange Nichts, dann kommt Luke Mockridge, und dann kommen wir. Dann kommen die Zauberer und dann kommen wir, kann man so sagen. Und dann kommt unsere Community. Denn die sind das Wichtigste, was sonst jemand passiert ist. Ich hatte heute eine Idee für einen visuellen Gag und ich würde dich ganz kurz nur fragen, ob das funktion... Ja, also ich würde dich ganz gerne ... Also, also ich würde dich ganz gerne, also ich habe jetzt direkt auf, wäre ein, ich war ganz kurz, ich habe direkt auf, wäre ein Disapp-Modus geschaltet, ich dachte, da kommt jetzt irgendwie, dein ganzes Leben ist ein visueller Gag oder deine Schuhe sind ein visueller Gag und ich war direkt schon auf Zurückschlagen-Modus, aber. Nein, nein, das kannst du vergessen, ich bin aus purer Freundschaft hier, ich mag was ihr. Über unsere Beziehung können wir später noch reden, mein Lieber, das möchte ich jetzt noch nicht vorgreifen. Ich gehe wieder raus, einfach mal. Und zwar folgendes, ich möchte von dir nur wissen, ob es visuell umsetzbar ist. Ja, oder nein. Und zwar, es gibt ja diese Schilder an Hotels, bitte nicht stören. Und meine Idee war, man sieht so einen Hotelkorridor an so einer Tür von außen und ich in Unterhose, also oder jede andere Figur steht da und hat von dem Bitte nicht stören das nicht durchgestrichen und hängt das so an die Tür und sagt dann so, von wegen heute Nacht schlafe ich nicht allein oder von wegen mal gucken was passiert, sowas in der Richtung, mal gucken was passiert, Hashtag heute Nacht schlafe ich nicht allein, so, ist es gut oder nicht? Das kannst du besser, das kannst du besser, weil das ist kein Visueller Gag Gag. Ja, aber ich dachte, weil man das sieht von außen, dann kann man das lesen, dass das da steht. Bitte nicht stören, das ist nicht durchgestrichen. Ja, kann man machen. Kann man machen, klar. Aber wie gesagt, das kannst du besser. Warte mal. Warte mal, ich habe auch mal einen visuellen Gag. Du hast ja viele... Nein, das ist jetzt nicht der beste Gag der Welt, die ist mir nur heute eingefallen. kann man machen, ja, ja, klar. Und ich dachte mir, den präsentier ich Ralf Rute. Es ist so, ich bekomme jeden Tag E-Mails von Leuten, die sagen, ich kann leider selbst nicht zeichnen, aber ich habe immer total lustige Ideen. Und dann kommt eine total grauenhafte Idee, und die ist in der Regel ein Karlauer. Es ist eigentlich immer ein Wortspiel, die kannst du vorausgehen. Unsere Hörer, die immer scheiss Gags schreiben, die wir immer machen sollen.
Also wer da draußen sitzt und denkt, professioneller Humor erschaffen ist doch einfach, die denken sich in der Regel einfach in Versprecher aus und denken dann, was sollte man zeichnen.
Oder schön war auch jemand, der mir halt irgendwie, also tatsächlich eine politische Karikatur diktieren wollte mit einer Waage und auf der linken Seite ist halt eben das Gesetz und auf der rechten Seite ist Meinung des Volkes oder irgendwie sowas. So moralische, politische Kutel. Also das bin ich normalerweise gewohnt. Und was du da gemacht hast, ist eigentlich ein Sketch. Denn ich sehe das eher als Sketch, dass da jemand das ja irgendwie auffängt und würde dann überlegen, da noch irgendwie anders rauszugehen, in dem vielleicht wirklich noch Leute da reinkommen, einmal wieder Raum in der Vorder,
oder ich habe keine Ahnung was, aber nur das finde ich jetzt
als Cartoon, ja, kannst du machen.
Ich würde nicht zu mir
passen, aber kannst du machen.
Ja, super. Stimmung im Arsch, ne?
Ist egal. Ich habe, das ist so ein bisschen,
die Niveaulatte, die wir mit Gästen
haben, die ist immer ein bisschen, aber mit dir
ist es schon wirklich sehr angenehm, muss man mal kurz sagen,
um ein bisschen was zurückzugeben.
Ich war auch sehr dankbar, du hast auch eine Zeichnung von mir, mal retweetet. Ja, den Batman, ne? Den Batman, den hast du favorisiert, glaube ich, und da habe ich mir, ich habe, glaube ich, jetzt Zeichnungen durchgespielt. Weil wenn Ralf Rudel plötzlich eine Zeichnung von dir, etwas, was ich noch nie gemacht habe. Es ist ja so, wenn du dich mit Humor beschäftigst, professionell, dann gibt es nicht immer einen grund die sachen auch zu zeichnen und das ist als zeichnung mega lustig mega lustig micky beisenherz der den ich auf vielen ebnen witzig finde und bei manchen sachen denke warum muss man da jetzt ein tweet von machen oder was auch immer aber der macht ja zum beispiel auch cartoons und ich finde die cartoons sind zum beispiel weit hinter dem was er sonst so an anglossen schreibt die ich teilweise brillant finde, weil ich denke, boah, der kann so geil schreiben. Und bei dir war diese Zeichnung nicht gut gezeichnet, sondern nein, diente dem Gag perfekt, das war super, das war hingeschludert, das war großartig. Mega, großartig. Das war ein echt guter Gag. Genial war das. War ein genialer Gag? War super. Der war echt gut. Nee, du hast vorhin gesagt, Hass wäre irgendwie jetzt das Wort, das du für uns, das du beschreiben würdest, wie ich zu dir stehe.
Ich würde sagen, es ist eher eine Mischung aus 80% Neid und 20% Ekel, so ein bisschen.
In der Zusammensetzung.
Also ob dann da letztendlich Hass bei rauskommt.
Darf ich denn den Kontext jetzt wissen, warum hast du das gesagt? Ach so, ja genau, sehr interessant.
Um ganz ehrlich zu sein, ich weiß es nicht mehr hundertprozentig, aber ich glaube, du hast irgendwie so eine politische Zeichnung gehabt oder irgendwie sowas mit Flüchtlingen oder sowas. Die Bäume? Ich weiss es nicht mehr genau oder irgendwie sowas Flüchtlingsmässiges geshared oder so und da überkam es mich plötzlich und dann dachte ich mir, ach dieser Rote, der ist doch scheiße. Wir sind aber auch, muss man sagen, alles kacke und wir übertreiben ja auch immer ein bisschen und sind auch nicht so ganz, es war nicht so ganz ernst. Ja doch, aber ich meine, nichtlustig.de ist halt einfach besser so, also muss man auch einfach sagen. Und du bist jetzt auch schon... Er wollte jetzt einen Film rausbringen, weißt du da was von? Ja klar, du bist ein guter Freund von mir. Ach, ein guter Freund? Das wisst ihr aber. Ach wie uncool, ich dachte, der wäre verfeindet oder so. Joshua, die sind seit 15 Jahren gute Freunde. Joshua Sauer, ne? Genau, und ich habe... Ja, den finde ich gut Ja, zu Recht. Völlig zu Recht. Und ich habe ja seinen, also er macht ja zum zweiten Mal einen Film, er hat ja schon mal einen Piloten gemacht. Also eigentlich, das war der Pilot und jetzt arbeitet er wirklich an der Serie. Nee, aber er könnte vielleicht mal ein paar ganzes über seinen Film reden. Ich finde, was mir besonders gut gefallen hat, dass er es irgendwie schafft, jeder Figur irgendwie so ein eigenes Leben zu geben. Irgendwie das kommt bei dir noch nicht so rauf. Oder? Also was kannst du dir genau von ihm abschauen? Wo kannst du noch was lernen? Eigentlich gar nichts. Ich habe dir mir ein paar Sachen aufgeschrieben, wo du vielleicht mal kurz drüber gucken kannst. Kurz um die Stimmung aufzulockern, eine Zwischenfrage, wann war dein erster Stand-Up-Auftritt? Ich hatte nur die Fragen von Luke Markgrit, ich weiß es auch nicht. Wann macht ihr das denn jetzt eigentlich? Ach 26.11. In einem Monat ungefähr. Haben wir einen Termin. Am 26.11? Wir haben einen Termin, wenn so ein Arzttermin wäre oder so. Ja, am 26.11. haben wir einen Termin. Da wird das rausgeschnitten. Genau, in fünf Minuten Zeit haben wir in so einem Stand-Up-Comedy-Club gehen können. Schade, da tritt ich glaube ich selber auf. Ich würde das sehr, sehr gerne sehen. Es ist aber tatsächlich, also man sagt das ja so, in einem Monat hat man einen Termin, aber mich hat heute Morgen ein Hörer angesprochen in der U-Bahn, also hallo an der Stelle, falls du zuhörst. Was auch ein krasses, erzähl mal bitte. Ja, der hat gesagt, hey, ich höre deinen Podcast und so, freut mich total und ich komme auch ins Boeing und ich schaue mir das an. Und in dem Moment, in dem dieser Mensch vor mir stand, hat es plötzlich eine ganz andere Dimension angenommen. So, ich dachte so, ja, du gehst auf die Bühne und erzählst was, aber plötzlich hast du diesen Menschen, dieses Wesen vor dir und du denkst, holy shit. Wie gross ist denn das Beugn? Ich habe keine Einschätzung. Enttäuschung ist schon eine Sache. 30 bis 50 Leute sind da bestimmt. 30. Das ist kein Scheiß. 100 Leute, wie viele fassen da rein? Auf keinen Fall. 30. Ja, das weiss ich, aber ich... 30, wirklich. Also ich würde tatsächlich fast sagen, je mehr, desto besser. Ich glaube, ich habe vor kleineren Gruppen eher Angst, weil das dann, glaube ich, schwerer ist. Oder ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe überhaupt keine Ahnung. Das ist aber vollkommen richtig. Also ich kenne es ja selbst, wie es ist, vor 30 Leuten aufzutreten und vor, das Größte war glaube ich, 1500. Und das ist so eine amorphe Masse. Da siehst du nicht mehr den Einzelnen und dann ist es fast egal. Aber die tra schon dynamisch, die haben ja Bock. Ja, in der Regel sind die ja da. Na gut, aber bei 30 Leuten traut sich eher jemand zu rufen, scheisse, als bei 1500, wenn das wirklich so eine Konglomeration oder so eine Masse. Ich meine, das ist ein Open Mic fünf Minuten, ich glaube, da würde jetzt niemand wirklich sagen, das ist scheisse. Wir haben Supporter da, unsere Podcast Community, unsere Podcast Antilopen, wie wir sie gerne nennen, oder unsere Podcast-Frädchen. Unsere kleinen Monsterchen. Unsere kleinen Astronauten. Aber warum kann ich das eigentlich noch schocken? Ich meine, du spielst doch schon vor der Kamera. Und dann schockt dich das, auf eine Bühne zu gehen. Ja, aber weißt du, eine Kamera ist was ganz anderes, weil du spielst wie die Kamera. Und du weißt, selbst wenn keiner im Publikum lacht, es ist auf Band, es wird ausgestrahlt, es läuft in einem Kontext, wo man sowieso schon gut drauf ist. Und Jan Böhrmann kommt da vor und danach und es ist eh schon gut und man hat eine wahnsinnig hohe Toleranz.
Also du fühlst dich da so, das ist es richtig, man fühlt sich total in ein Nest eingebaut.
Und wie gesagt, da ist es auch nicht unangenehm, wenn jemand lacht, weil ich weiß, man macht es primär für die Kamera und das ist einfach abgedehnt und es hat ja auch so einen Produktionsflair, so dieses okay, du komm raus, mach Star-City und gehst wieder raus und es hat sowas sehr, man produziert eher eine Sendung für die Kamera als jetzt wirklich für eine Show fürs Publikum, also man kann es natürlich unterschiedlich auslegen, aber so kann man sich das immer vor Augen führen. Und du kannst ja noch gut schneiden. Der Podcast ist ja furchtbar eigentlich. Wir schneiden dem nachher noch die Gags rein.
Und die Reaktion des Publikums.
Und die Gäste auch oft. Das ist ein riesen Redaktionsteam, was hinter uns steht, wo wir dann noch setzen, wir brauchen noch bessere Gags und dann synchronisiere ich das noch nach. Wir bringen Monate im Studio. Mit verschiedenen Stimmen. Das produzieren wir ja gerade eigentlich im Jahre 2012 sind wir ja gerade. Und ihr hört das im Jahre 2015, aber in Wirklichkeit haben wir das jahrelang produziert. Das ist der Trick. Das war unter so einer betonplatte eigentlich eingegraben und wir haben das jetzt rausgehoben dass das alles drauf ist zusammen mit deinen kassetten die pferde laufen schnell Kartoffelbrei Hex Hex kennt ihr noch Kartoffelbrei kennt ihr noch oder und was hast du gesprochen an irgendwie am 11. September oder vorher dann bin ich ernst habe ich hatte, aber ich hatte eine Folge zum Thema Geld. Heute sind ganz viele Menschen getötet worden und im Hintergrund, yeah, Bibi, mach schneller, heul, die Welt ist wundervoll, ja, heute sind drei Milliarden Menschen gekommen. Die sind hundert Stockwerke in die Tiefe gestürzt und ich habe Videos gesehen, wie die unten aufgekommen sind. Und ich fand es eigentlich ganz geil. Ich fand es eigentlich ganz geil. Schnell, Bibi, schnell, wir müssen Adam retten. Also war eine ganz gute Zeit eigentlich als Kind. Ich hatte eine Folge zum Thema Geld und da habe ich Geld erklärt. Du hast Geld erklärt. Habe ich Geld erklärt, einfach mal so, ja, Freunde, wie funktioniert eigentlich Geld? Hast du was, bist du was, Gelle. Und tatsächlich ganz geil, weil da kam im nächsten Jahr der Euro raus, also muss es ungefähr 2000 gewesen sein. Haben die wegen dir gemacht bestimmt, weil du Geld erklärt hast. Genau, aber das Geile war, ich wusste zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht, wie die Unterform von Euro heißt, also wie Cent heißt und deswegen habe ich einfach improvisiert und ich nannte sie Eurolinge. Ich habe gesagt, ich dachte so, ja, also ein Euro besteht aus 100 Eurolingen und ein Euro ist dann ungefähr so viel wert wie zwei Mark oder zwei Euro, eine Mark, aber das wird sich, also ich habe überhaupt gar keine Ahnung, wird einfach irgendwas erklärt. Worüber hast du denn gesprochen, also wie Geld, also als Kind hast du einen Zusammenhang, du verstehst das große und ganz ehrlich, das große Bild. Ja, aber das Tolle ist, also ich, bei mir bestand Erklärung primär aus Aufzählung, also ich habe gesagt, also es geht man. Man kann Folgendes mit Geld kaufen. Autos, Türen, Lichtschalter, Fenster, Freunde, Angst. Genauso habe ich es gesagt. Man kann verschiedene Dinge kaufen, wie Autos, aber dann kann man auch Dinge, die kann man nicht mit Geld kaufen, wie Freundschaft, Liebe und solche Sachen. Das ist aber voll schön, das ist auch schon sehr reflektiert, oder? Ja, sehr reflektiert. Naja, das sind Phrasen, die Kinder nachplappern, diese man kann Freunde nicht mit Geld kaufen, was Bullshit ist, also, Entschuldigung, aber... Was hast du mit fünf Jahren gemacht? Hast du auch schon Sachen aufgenommen? Hast du auch schon... Also ich habe vor allem meinen besten Freund Norbert Pudens, wir haben immer... Wir haben der Norbert, der Nobby, Alter, wie geht's da in Rade du? Ah, der ist so los, eigentlich dem Nobby. Alter, das weiss ich noch, den mochte ich immer viel lieber als dich. Das letzte Mal, als ich ihn gesehen habe, hatte der so eine Schrebergartenkneipe in Düsseldorf. Keil. Aber das ist lange her. Kannst du mir die Nummer mal geben von dem, dass wir den vielleicht noch mal einladen? Gerne, ja. Wir wissen auch nicht, ob wir die Folge hier hochladen, weil ... Kann ich verstehen. Gerade bei ... Wir wollen nur nicht hier hochladen, weil gerade bei visuell arbeitenden Menschen ist das immer ein riesiges Risiko. Zurück zur Frage. Also, Norbert, genau, wir haben Klassikradio laufen lassen und haben uns dazu Hörspiele improvisiert, weil da änderte sich ja permanent die Stimmung. Das heisst, erst fängt es so an so ein Waldstück, eine offene Wiese, Leute laufen rüber, alles ist gut drauf und dann mit einmal verändert sich die Stimmung, alles wird total gefährlich, oh da kommt ein böser Mann aus dem Gebüsch und ich glaube das sind Piraten oder Hehler, wir müssen denen folgen und dann gehen die zu uns. Ein fünfjähriges Kind, das sind wahrscheinlich Hehler. Das sind bestimmt Hehler, die uns an die Kragen wollen. Hat der Halt TKKG gehört.
Und ja, all diese Sachen.
Und dann haben wir über diese Musik, die ja ein Score war, haben wir dann Hörspiele improvisiert. Ach, das ist ja geil. Das ist eine mega geile Idee. Das sollten wir auch mal machen. Ich habe aber diese Kassetten leider nicht mehr. Wenn ich sie finden sollte. Ja, bitte. Wow, dann schickst du uns. Ich lasse sie auf Soundcloud hoch. Super gut. Statt dieses Interviews und Gesprächs laden wir das dann noch. Wir schneiden das so untereinander, dass es beides gleichzeitig läuft. Podcast, da hat man etwa drei Hörebenen. Aber Wald ist für dich auch ein Thema, oder? Also weil du es gerade gesagt hast, fröhlicher Wald, du verbindest Wald mit Kindheit, Jugend, gute Luft, rausgehen, Bäumen. Also geh da mal bitte ein bisschen näher drauf ein. Hast du auch eine Frage, Stefan? Irgendwas? Du kannst dir die bessere aussuchen von uns beiden. Gibt es eine L habe tatsächlich, ohne Scheisse, ich hatte wirklich keine Zeit, mich auf die Situation vorzubereiten. Und da du dich selber eingeladen hast, sympathischerweise, habe ich leider auch... Du hast uns Fragen vorbereiten sollen. Nein, deswegen habe ich komplett die Motivation verloren. Bei New Yorker waren wir halt so aufgeregt, weil wir dachten, wir können unsere Halter nicht verlieren, wir wollen ihn nicht zu weich rannehmen, wir wollen aber auch geile Antworten bekommen. Lass uns jetzt mal nicht über, lass noch mal ein bisschen über Norbert reden, bitte. Über Joshua Sauer reden. Beides gute Freunde, warum nicht? Ich habe folgende Frage, ich habe eben gelesen, dass dich jemand nach Florentins Autogramm angepumpt hat, wo ich folgende Frage stellen müsste. Wie tief muss man Autogrammsammler technisch sinken, um von Florentin Will um Ralf Ruthie um ein Autogramm von Florentin Will zu bitten? Entschuldigung. Ich kann's erklären. Vor allem kennst du den? Ja. Sascha Brom ist ein guter Freund von mir. Wer ist kein guter Freund von mir? Nein, Hum, Humorautor, leider, und Sascha tut mir leid, das ist so, du hast es selbst gesagt, vor zwei Tagen ziemlich erfolglos, der hat viel so Lesebühensachen gemacht und ihr, also ohne Scheiss, ihr würdet es lieben, ihr würdet es lieben, weil das völlig unerwartete Absurd, grandiose Dinge haben bei mir immer so einen Nebengeschmack. So, und ich muss dazu sagen, ich glaube, er steht einfach auf dich. Er findet dich hot. Aber tatsächlich, und ich glaube, es gibt niemanden zu, aber ich glaube, ich habe zwischen dem Alter von 15 und 18 Autogramme geübt. Ich habe meine Unterschrift geübt und Autogramme, ja, aber nicht meine Unterschrift, vor allem, ich habe mir tatsächlich auch ein System überlegt. Weil ich dachte mir, also ich habe wirklich ernsthaft damit gerechnet, dass ich in meinem Leben mehrere tausend Autogramme geben werde. Und deswegen dachte ich mir... Hast du schon? Ich habe vielleicht drei Autogramme gegeben in meinem Leben. Aber ich habe mir folgendes überlegt. Es gibt verschiedene Seltenheitsgrade für meine Autogrammen. Ich dachte mir, ich dachte mir ganz ausgefuchst. Meinen normalen Schriftzug mache ich als Autogramm und bei jedem Zehnten mache ich einen Strich und drunter... Mit Blitzerschrift! Nee, lass mich ganz kurz ausreden, Stefan. Ich glaube nicht, dass seine Einwürfe lustiger sind als meine Geschichte. Deswegen möchte ich schon. Ich wollte nur kurz auch mal was einwerfen, ich weiß nicht, wir wollten hier ein bisschen Humor. Ja, aber dann überleg bitte davor, bevor du das machst, ansonsten führst du uns nichts. Ja, hoffentlich führt deine Geschichte irgendwo hin. Wir haben die Geschichte angefangen und deswegen, auch wenn es jetzt nichts führt, wäre es glaube ich besser, dass wir es jetzt weiterführen, als wenn wir hier an der Stelle aufreffen. Ja,, dann rede doch einfach mal bitte. Nee, rede du doch einfach mal, wenn du so gerne redest, dann rede du einfach. Ich bitte, dass du jetzt weiter sprichst. Wie bitte? Ist gut, macht ruhig. Und dann dachte ich mir, bei jedem zehnten Autogramm mache ich einen Strich unten drunter und bei jedem zwanzigsten Autogramm mache ich einen Strich drunter und noch einen Sternchen. Und bei jedem fünfzigsten mache ich einen Strich drunter, Sternchen und zwei Sternen, immer so weiter, bis irgendwie jedes tausendste Autogramm mache ich dann Strich drunter, Sternchen, Smiley, also immer mehr Elemente.
Und dann dachte ich mir, dass Leute irgendwann so Foren gründen, wo sie sagen, boah, ich habe hier eins gefunden mit einem Strich und die Ratio eins zu zehn.
Die blaue Mauritius.
Genau, und die werden dann immer...
Hier, das andere mit dem Hakenkreuz.
Ja, genau.
Eines und der seltensten.
Sehr guter Einwurf. Und die werden dann immer wahnsinnig teurer gehandelt und dann sagt man, boah, irgendjemand...
Und dann stelle ich mir so vor, wie ich dann irgendwie am roten Teppich so tausendmal das Autogramm gebe und dann irgendwie ein kleiner Junge oder so steht da und dem gebe ich dann so die Mörder-Euterschrift, die es nur ein einziges Mal in der ganzen Welt gibt. Und er versteht das noch gar nicht und geht nach Hause und geht in die Foren und liest nach und Moment mal, Strich, Moment, Moment, Sternchen, Strich, Hakenkreuz, Moment mal, das ist doch dieses, das ist, das ist sie, das ist die einzigartige, die es mehrere Millionen Euro wert, das habe ich mir wirklich alles überlegt und verschiedene Designvorsteige und um deine Frage zu beantworten, nein, ich kann dir leider kein Autogramm geben, wie narzisstisch, ach komm, du kannst doch irgendwas, wir werden doch hier Blatt Papier finden, was ist mit der Abgeburte, du hast übrigens Kekse mitgebracht und, ja, hab ich doch gesagt, ich bringe Kekse mit, ja, aber dann mach die bitte auch auf, damit wir die auch essen können, weil, lieber die mit Schoki oder, obwohl, obwohl, die sind ja... Lass mal mit den Kleinen. Die finde ich gut, die finde ich super. Die haben wir hier stehen. Die haben wir hier schön drapiert. Aber es ist nie narzisstisch, ich habe ja primär meine Fans wieder. Das ist geil für Radio. Essen. Vakuumverpackte Schokoladenkekse. Hast du die gleiche Unterschrift, die du dann auf deine Comics machst, machst du die auch auf deinem Personalausweis und so? Ja, ja, ich kann nur die. Also die habe ich, da sind wir uns wieder sehr nahe, lieber Florentin, die habe ich mir nämlich auch früh überlegt, ich glaube in elf oder so und war mir sehr sicher, dass eine schicke Unterschrift auch irgendwie dazu gehört, wenn man in irgendeiner Form Künstler ist.
Nie, es gibt keinen Künstler, den eine hessische Unterschrift hat. Ist eine gewagte These, stimmt mit Sicherheit nicht, wollte ich mal rein.
Ich schau mir ganz kurz deine Unterschrift mal an. Auf wie viele Unterschriften basiert diese Aussage? Zwei. Ich kenne Florendin und ich kenne meine. Ich habe auch meine Unterschrift geübt und ich musste auch ein paar Dinge unterschreiben, weil ich damals in einer Band gespielt habe. Mit deiner Punkband, ich hörte davon. Mit meiner Punkband und wir haben mit der Binky Zagbu. Das waren noch mal schon lustige Kerle. Und wir haben damals in so Jugendzentren gespielt und da wollten auch Leute mein Autogramm haben. Was hast du gespielt? Bass und hab gesungen. Gesungen? Das ist eine geile Kombination. Geile Kombination, die nicht funktioniert. Ich hab immer aufgehört Bass zu spielen, wenn ich gesungen hab. Vor allem weil der Bassist ja eigentlich schon eher immer so, ne, eigentlich weit hinten ist. Ist eigentlich die coolen, die hinten stehen, ähm, so von der Statur her ist gepasst, ein bisschen zu gross. Stimmt, Jugendzeitraum. Jugendzeitraum, da haben wir dann halt gespielt und dann wollten auch Leute Autogramme haben. Und da habe ich mir zum ersten Mal diese Frage gestellt, wie tief muss man eigentlich sinken als Autogrammanfrager, was muss bei dem alles schief gelaufen sein, um dann zu mir zu kommen Autogramm zu wollen. Deswegen frage ich mich auch, wieso wird man von Foto in Flur in Autogramm. Aber hast du schon mal auf was anderes als ein Stück Papier unterschrieben? Gewisse Körperteile, gewisse Körpersäfte, T-Shirts und Körper? Brüste, viele Brüste, links und rechts? Beides. Also einmal stellend über Stefan Tietze, aber ich habe beide Namen. Geil. Aber falls ihr zu den Glücklichen gehört, die der Rezipientin davon wurden, einfach mal ein Foto schicken. Oh ja, von ihren Tattoos, ich habe auch viel tatuiert. Ja, aber ich glaube, das ist die Idee. Im Gesicht im Tattooing. Ich glaube, das ist ernsthaft die Idee von Leuten, die sich von Stars Unterschriften auf die Haut setzen lassen. Weil ich würde mir denken, das ist ja dumm, weil du wäschest ja irgendwann ab. Aber ich glaube, die Idee dahinter ist tatsächlich, dass man sich das nachsträchtigt. Also ist auf jeden Fall schon passiert. Ich weiß, dass ich schon mal mit Henning irgendwo drauf gemalt habe und dann hat er sich das nachsträchen lassen. Aber du unterschreib nachher mit Uli Stein, oder weil es ein bisschen unangenehm ist. Mit Gunga. Weil du denkst, dass Leute denken, dass es Uli Stein wird. Ich kann das nicht empfehlen. Du bist so der lustige Cartoonist und du sagst, ja, okay, Uli Stein, ich war schon gedenkt. Ich kann das nicht empfehlen, dass Leute sich das von mir vorzeichnen lassen, weil viel schöner ist es, einen guten Tätowierer ranzulassen und zu sagen, der nimmt sich einen Originalkartoon und zeichnet es dann ab, dann kann das ganz geil aussehen.
Ich habe da schöne Beispiele gesehen, aber wenn ich das vorher so einfach so mit dem Edding draufmale, sieht es in der Regel schrottig aus, weil das ist nicht die Unterlage, auf der ich sonst arbeite. Haut. Haut. Vielleicht ist es doch, vielleicht schaust du es dir nicht offen zuzugeben, dass eigentlich deine Unterlage Haut ist. Oh Gott. Also ein ganz weirdes Studio, bei der du zu Hause einfach auf Haut zeichnet bist. Ich glaube, unsere Hörer werden ein bisschen enttäuscht, wenn wir Ralper Ruthie hier zu Gast haben und nicht ein bisschen über seine wilde Jugendzeit reden würden.
Deswegen würde ich da gerne mit einer Anekdote anfangen, die ich ausgegraben habe.
Ich habe mich auch ein bisschen informiert tatsächlich, Herr Rutte.
Was ist die Anekdote über Herrn... Habe ich tatsächlich gefunden, ich habe ein paar Interviews mit dir durchforstet,
und da ist mir eine Geschichte immer wieder aufgekommen, und zwar die Lux-Geschichte.
Und ich glaube, du weisst, worauf ich hinausrege.
Also das Irre ist, für einen Moment habe ich geglaubt, es kommt was, was stimmt.
Ne, Moment, lass uns einmal darauf eingehen.
Ich habe nämlich aus einigen Instagram-Fotos geschlussfolgert, dass du mal einen Lux zusammengeschlagen hast. Ja. Wie ist das, wie ist das dazu gekommen? Alkohol. Aber ist das ja, also es ist ja rechtlich nicht ganz einwandfrei, aber hast du, weil, also nach dem Gesetz der... Die einen sagen so, die anderen sagen so, also, entsprechend den Anwalt, das ist alles völlig sauber. Aber nach dem Gesetz der Natur gehört... Bin ich unter... also in einer Nahrungsdurchstehung luchs jetzt dir also natürlich das revier des luchses jetzt dir also natürlich du hast ihm glaube ich mit einem schlag den kopf abgeschlagen und es war relativ schnell vorbei und dann ein revier umkotet und damit ist es ja offiziell aber was ist das jetzt was machst du damit also gucken flüchtlingsheim natürlich ja da weil also jeder muss was machen Ist das so? Muss echt jeder was machen oder was? Ist das so? So diese alte Pfad von der Regel, man muss jeden Tag ein Flüchtlingsheim natürlich, hierzu. Jeder muss was machen. Muss echt jeder was machen. Ist das so? Diese alte Fahrtfinderregel, man muss jeden Tag ein Flüchtlingsheim bauen, glaube ich, oder? Die alte Fahrtfinderregel? Jeder Tag eine gute Tag. Egal wie groß. Also auch aufs Lego. Jeder Tag eine gute Tag ist, glaube ich, auch mittlerweile jeden Tag ein Flüchtlingsheim bauen. Bin mir da nicht so sicher. Jeden Tag ein Wahl zurück ins März. Ja. Würdest du das machen? Ich war mal Fahrtfinderreg. Ein Wal zurück ins März. Ja. Klar, wer würde das machen? Ist es nicht als Wal extrem schwer, Selbstmord zu begehen, weil immer irgendwelche scheiß Greenpeace-Idioten am Strand schrägen? Allerdings. Ist das ein Comic? Das ist nicht schlecht. Das ist nicht schlecht. Okay, aber wie will der aussehen? Wie will der aussehen? Der Wal liegt auf dem Strand ausgetrocknet, ganz viele Leute stehen da rum und er sagt. Du bist nah dran an einem aktuell von mir hochgeladenen Video, muss ich dazu sagen, was du natürlich wahrscheinlich nicht gesehen hast, weil du meine Arbeit hast, die neue Flossenfolge, wo der kleine gelbe Fisch versucht, einen Wal zurück ins Meer zu ziehen, der aber einfach nur mal ein bisschen am Strand liegen und chillen will und dann ist die Szene auch schon wieder vorbei. Das heisst, da wollte er wirklich einfach nur chillen und wurde zurück ins Meer gez. Gut, Humor, Kritiker Tietze, ganz kurz. Ist es nicht besser, wenn man dann drastisch den Weg geht und er will sich umbringen? Aha, immer in Extrem denken. In Extrem. Hat mehr Fallhöhe, Tod ist immer Fallhöhe, sehr gut. Klar, Fallhöhe ist das... Ich weiß mit den Bördern, L-Form, Fallhöhe, Pannstein, Absurdität. Ja, ist nicht schlecht, finde ich gut. Aber wie gehst du jetzt ran? Du hast die Idee und jetzt denkst du, es gibt ja Farben und es gibt ja Formen, es gibt Geometrie, es gibt Kubismus, es gibt Impressionismus, Expressenismus, es gibt verschiedene, es gibt McDonald's, es gibt Burger King. Wie gehst du jetzt ran an so eine Idee? Ich merke das in euren Gesprächen, dass ihr schon sehr analytisch daran geht, ich nicht. Also ich habe Sachen immer aus dem Bauch gemacht und würde da jetzt einfach einen Stift nehmen und anfangen zu überlegen, wie setze ich das visuell um. Und in der Regel sieht es dann meist schon so aus, wie ich es dann hinterher umsetze und ich sage mal, im Drittel der Fälle ist es so, dass ich irgendwas hinschmiere, denke, ah, das ist es noch nicht, leg es weg und dann nehme ich es mir eine Woche später oder einen Monat später oder ein halbes Jahr später und dann mache ich es irgendwie anders. Aber eigentlich nehme ich einen Stift, schmiere es auf und dann weiss ich, aha, das ist die Bildkomposition, die Figur ist da, die ist da, immer darum muss ich noch das Element, damit alles einen Sinn ergibt oder der Leser weiss, wo er sich befindet und dann habe ich den Cartoon. Aber es gibt da auch nicht den einen Weg, gibt es ja für einen Sketch-Skript auch nicht. Für den optimalen Gag gibt es keinen richtigen Weg. Hast du eigentlich ein, hast du einen Cartoon komplett ohne Text? Ja klar. Also wirklich ganz ohne Text, also nicht nur keine gesprochene Sprache, sondern auch gar keinen Text. Ich habe sogar eine Nummer in meinem Live-Programm, die heißt Ohne viele Worte, wo man nur Cartoons ohne Text sieht. Aber dann ist ja Ohne Worte. Ein schöner Song darunter läuft, ja genau. Da ist der Gag schon im Namen, Ohne viele Worte, gut, ist ein Gag, weil ich nur gar keine Worte. Also ich habe das viele in Klammern, weil ich glaube, in einem Gag macht es im Mittagrund einmal Kracks oder so, hat sie deuten, dass er immer auf einen Ast tritt, aber es ist einer von 20 Cartoons. Du merkst, wie das Karten aus Ralf Rudhe gerade in sich zusammenfällt, ne? Einfach nicht konsequent. Nee, nicht konsequent. Aber es zieht sich auch ein bisschen durch dein Leben. Das so auf dieser Lux-Geschichte jetzt wieder, wir waren gerade... Mich fasziniert das nur so, weil ich denke mir, klar, natürlich gab es da familiäre Probleme irgendwie zwischen euch, aber dass man das dann so ... Ich meine, war das die Zeit, wo du in der Telefonzelle gewohnt hast, oder war das dann danach, oder wie? Ich muss mal ganz kurz reingrätschen. Es gibt übrigens, hast du auch die Folge gehört, wo wir zum Humorkongress nach Basel wollten? Ich habe wirklich nur die Folgen der Gäste gehört. Zu mir war noch keine Zeit, weil ich habe mich ja erst vor zwei Wochen entdeckt. Ach ja, erst zwei Wochen entdeckt. Das Interessante ist nämlich, dass der Humorkongress Basel, zu dem wir gerne hinwollten, weil das ist nämlich, wir haben nämlich geguckt, nach Gelotologie heißt das glaube ich, das ist die Wissenschaft von Humor. Heißt die wirklich so? Ja, weiß ich nicht genau. Humorologie war da nicht. Ich glaube, da ist der Wikipedia-Eintrag doch wieder in der Ich-Form geschrieben, oder? Bau, bau, bau, Luke-Mockridge-Gags, bam, bam. Nee, und da ist es nämlich so... Das ist viel lustiger als Luke-Mockridge, er macht auch die Luke-Mockridge-Gags viel besser. Und da haben wir herausgefunden, dass es einen Humorkongress gibt tatsächlich, wo wir gerne hinwollten, haben wir leider verpasst. Und jetzt hat Florentin Bilder entdeckt. Ganz kurz, kann ich ganz kurz... Bilder entdeckt. Wir haben ihn verpasst, heißt. Wir haben davon erfahren, haben dann unsere Community gebeten, uns Geld zu geben. Unsere Community hat uns Geld gegeben. Wie viel? Mehrere Millionen. Dann hat Stephen Teets vergessen, Karten dafür zu reservieren. Die Karten wurden dann irgendwann so teuer, dass wir sie es nicht leisten konnten. Dann hatten wir das ganze Geld von unserer Community. Wir reden nur noch vom Humorkongress Basel. Dann hatten wir das ganze Geld von unserer Community und konnten nicht hinfahren, haben uns wahnsinnig schlecht gefühlt. Dann habe ich alles Geld wieder zurücküberwiesen, jedem einzelnen. Ey, wir können nicht... Wir machen das steuerrechtlich, da wird doch irgendjemand, der erfragt wird. Du steuerrechtlich will ich ja gar nicht anfangen. Wir dachten, wir können jetzt nicht der Ralf Ruther der Podcastszene werden und hier irgendwie massiv Steuergeld entdecken, das funktioniert nicht, deswegen haben wir alles Geld wieder zurücküberwiesen, aus Schaf. Aber immer mit einem lustigen Gag im Betreff. Man kennt das so. Die ersten vier waren noch ganz gut danach, glaube ich. Ich glaube, da wurde es ein bisschen schwierig. Wir haben nur noch Bilder gemalt von irgendwelchen Leuten. Wie lange ist das her? Zwei Wochen. Humorkongress Basel. Humorkongress Basel. Und der hat jetzt stattgefunden. Und der hat jetzt stattgefunden und die Bilder sind da. Und da du ja ein sehr visueller Mensch bist, dachten wir uns... Wir analysieren jetzt die Bilder vom Humorkongress Basel. Nein, auf keinen Fall. Aber erzähl doch mal, was ist da so alles passiert jetzt? Vielleicht auch für dich interessant. Wir sind ja alle drei Leute, die sich mit Humor beschäftigen. Nein, doch, ja klar. Viel zu viel beschäftigen, würde ich fast sagen. Und vielleicht... Ich beschäftige mich eigentlich gar nicht so aber gut. Ich denke, ich produziere so nie. Aber ich glaube, man könnte da... Ja, aber das ist ja auch damit beschäftigen. Ah ja, okay. Oder? Ich glaube, man könnte da... Ja, bitte. Ich glaube, man könnte ein sehr schönes Spiel machen. Man zeigt Bilder und muss raten. Humorkongress oder Holocaust-Gedenkfeier. Es ist alles wahnsinnig ernst. Sieht man lachende Menschen? Nein, Charlotte Hüffners Humorimpuls wird aufmerksam verfolgt und wir sehen hier einfach sieben alte Menschen, die zwischen Halbnarkose und Halbtot da stehen. Ich will jetzt nicht über den Humorkonkrest da... Doch, ganz kurz, nein, nein, aber... Das ist nicht fair. Es ist so, Anfang der Nuller habe ich ja angefangen bei Matt Zeug zu machen. Oh ja, Matt Magazine. Genau, und da gab es in den...
Die, die in Amerika wesentlich lustiger sind als Deutschland.
Richtig. Und da gab es auf den redaktionellen Seiten immer Werbung für auch so eine Art Humorakademie in Köln, die angeblich von Rudi Carell ins Leben gerufen worden war. Cool. Und nein, das exakte Gegenteil von cool. Rudi Carell. Damals habe ich das gelesen und habe gedacht, was, wie, das kann doch nicht wahr sein, dass man wirklich, und da sollte einem wirklich das Handwerk des Comedy-Autoren und aber auch so die Grundzüge von Stand-Up beigemacht werden. Das gibt es immer noch. Ich gucke mal, also ich werde diese Ausgaben finden und dann gucke ich mal, wie das hieß. Und da waren manche nämlich auch Fotos bei, also mit Leuten an Flipcharts, die so erklären. Genau, hier zum Beispiel haben wir Hans-Georg Lauer mit Humor für Anfänger. Der lauert doch schon auf einen Witz. Also das hier vor allem ist ein Bild, wir können das ja mal, ich kann euch den Link mal, ihr findet das auch selber, keine Ahnung, wie das jetzt logistisch vonstatten kommt. Was glaubt ihr wirklich denn? Wir haben ja tatsächlich, Informatik ist nicht so mein Ding, ich habe ja unter anderem auch diese Woche einfach mal die gesamte Website unseres Podcasts gelöscht. Das habe ich gelesen, wo ich ganz kurz auch nochmal auf Existenzängste eingehen möchte. Das ist wirklich passiert? Wir denken uns, dass alles das Lustige ist, alle Dinge, die man vielleicht für lustig halten könnte, die wir im Podcast mal jemandem erzählen, die passieren uns wirklich, wir denken uns das nicht aus. Wir sind Dinge, die uns überhaupt nicht, die passieren uns noch schlimmer, wir müssen ein bisschen runterkoppeln vom Podcast, damit es nicht ein bisschen Glaubieder rüberkommt. Das mit dem Lux war vielleicht... Und jetzt hat Florentin die ganze WordPress-Seite gelöscht, wo ich kurz dachte, okay, mein Schaffen von einem Jahr ist jetzt womöglich komplett weg. Ist im Nirvana... Das ist ja nur ein Zweig deiner Arbeit. Na ja, es ist ein Grossteil. Du schaffst ja schon noch viel mehr. Ja gut, aber es ist schon wichtig. Du bist ja auch täglich hier ausgepresst wie eine Zitrone. Ja, das stimmt, aber mit dem Florotin ist schon ganz wichtig. Es war tatsächlich... Es war erschrecken, wie schnell das weg sein kann. Ja. Es war einfach so, wo man sehr viel Zeit reinsteckt. Es war tatsächlich pure Dummheit. Ich wollte auf einer anderen Website einen neuen Blog installieren und habe dann aus Versehen eben die Podcast-Ufo-Seite angegeben und dann hat er noch mal gefragt, so wollen Sie überschreiben und so. Und ich so, ja, klar. Das dachte ich mir auch. Wie viele Schranken musst du mit dem Kopf durchgelaufen sein aber das ist tatsächlich also ich will jetzt nicht sagen ich bin der mega programmier oder so aber wirklich auch überhaupt ganz klar aber gerade wenn man sich mit diesem sag ich mal semi-informatik-Themen befasst es geht wahnsinnig schnell wahnsinnig großen Schaden anzurichten so auf deinem normalen PC hast du immer wollen sie es wirklich alles löschen wollen sie wirklich nicht nochmal ein Backup an anlegen und man hat sowieso immer alles nochmal in der Cloud und alles in der Dropbox, aber da bei solchen Sachen gibst du einmal einschränkig Delete und alles ist weg, ohne dass sich jemand so mal fragt. Und ich habe das tatsächlich leider dumm überschritten, überschrieben, und dann es gibt nichts Schlimmeres als diesen Moment, wenn du auf die Seite gehst und du siehst komplett leer und dann dieses kurze Versteinern und eiskalt über den Rücken laufen, es ist alles weg, du wirst alles gelöscht. Dann kamen die SMS mit, ich habe massivem Scheiss gebaut. Wir können ja vielleicht nochmal unseren Verlauf tatsächlich rekonstruieren. Ihr schickt euch SMS? Ihr seid nicht so WhatsApp, Leute? Wir schicken uns meistens Videonachrichten, kurze Videos von uns. Hey, wie war die aufgestanden, wie geht's dir, sowas sind wir eigentlich, wir sind jetzt visuelle Menschen. Aber hast du die Angst, dass irgendwann mal alles von dir weg ist? Nein. Das fand ich übrigens auch sehr interessant bei dem Interview mit Luke, der, das muss ich jetzt auch mal sagen, einfach mega sympathisch rübergekommen ist, da war Angst ein grosses Thema hatte ich das Gefühl. Zukunftsängste.
Ja, ja.
Aber so ein Künstlerding, glaube ich, so ein bisschen dieses in eine Schublade gesteckt werden,
dieses Öffentlichkeitskünstlerding, Künstler in der Öffentlichkeit, die immer so diese Angst haben.
Also die Angst, dass alles weg sein könnte oder dass mir nichts mehr einfällt, habe ich gar nicht,
aber ich mache es auch einfach schon so mega lange.
Ich habe mit 14 angefangen, damit Geld zu verdienen.
Crazy.
Und das hat mir so eine Grunde.
Wo dann damals?
Ich habe Geschichten geschrieben für das Kundenheft der Volksbank.
Das ist ein sehr guter Punkt. aber ich mache es auch einfach schon so mega lange. Ich habe mit vierzehn angefangen damit Geld zu verdienen. Und das hat mir so eine... Wo dann damals? Ich habe Geschichten geschrieben für das Kundenheft der Volksbank, das Mike-Malazin. Und da habe ich mir Comicgeschichten ausgedacht. Bist du denn da angekommen als vierzehnjähriger? Ich habe denen einfach Briefe geschickt. Ich habe denen Leserbriefe geschickt mit meinen Comicseiten. Ich war... Hundert pro Tag. Und die... Okay, wir nehmen die da auch. Kein Scheiss, du bist verdammt nah dran. Ich war neun oder zehn und habe Aber einfach Redaktionen, das ist ganz lustig, dass ich jetzt erzähle, weil das ist eigentlich die Standardgeschichte, die ich in Interviews erzähle, weil Leute fragen, wie hat das denn angefangen? Jetzt kommen wir zum ersten Mal in diesem Gespräch an den Punkt, wo ich ansatzweise was erzähle. Erzähl sie nochmal, aber lüge komplett. Ich lüge komplett. Also, ich habe einen freundlichen Luchs im Wald getroffen, der spielte eine Querflöte und sagte, wenn du wirklich etwas erreichen möchtest in deinem Leben, dann musst du Comic-Redaktionen anschreiben. Alle, oft. Ich habe einfach nur die Comic-Redaktionen genommen, von denen ich gedacht habe, da sitzen, also bei Mickey Mouse habe ich gedacht, das sind ja Amerikaner, die können ja meine Briefe nicht verstehen. Aber sehr reflektiert als Neunjähriger, 14-Jähriger. Idiotisch, aber trotzdem reflektiert, es gab ja eine deutsche Redaktion natürlich, das war mir aber nicht klar. Also habe ich an Fix und Foxy geschrieben und auch an das Mike Heft der Volksbanken, weil ich damals die Qualität gesehen habe. Das waren wirklich gut gemachte Comics für einen Kunden Heft der Volksbank, aber die Qualität gesehen als vierzehnjähriger. Ich stelle mir gerade, wie du da irgendwie sitzen, so eine Checkliste. Nein, ich war neun, ich war neun. Aber also der Wahnsinn, die Blatt waren mir da in der Klinik. Wir haben visuelle Gags, die Bildafteilung ist wunderbar. Ich würde insgesamt für dich präsentieren, eine Gedeifung zu geben. Ich denke, die sind bereit für meine Arbeit.
Und dann habe ich denen einfach Leserbriefe geschickt und habe wirklich mal Zeug dazu gepackt und gesagt, hier wäre toll, wenn sie es abdrucken.
Und die haben es natürlich nicht abgedruckt, weil es noch totaler Dreck war.
Aber auch die haben anscheinend irgendwie gesehen, okay, grundsätzlich Potenzial.
Und dann ist eine Brieferundschaft entstanden und dann bekam ich... Zwischen einem 45-jährigen Mann und einem 40-jährigen Jungs, der gesagt hat, mal doch mal ein paar Bilder von dir. Schick mir doch mal ein paar Bilder von dir. Am Strand vielleicht. Ich sag mal, es hat nicht geschadet. In der Badewanne oder so. Genau, und mit den Füchsen, Fix und Foxy vielleicht noch daneben. Wie hessen die von der Sparkasse? Knacks. Ah, genau, Knacks, ja, genau. Die haben auch ... Also ich bin zwei alten, ganz alten Männern an Sparchen, ich habe keine Ahnung, wovon die redet. Ich bin komplett raus. Doch, ich bring's kurz zu Ende. Alles klar. Und jeweils kam dann mit vierzehnten einmal ein Scheck, obwohl ich denen überhaupt nichts geschickt habe, wo ich jetzt davon ausgegangen bin, dass sie abdrucken würden. Ich hatte eigentlich eine Serie von denen parodiert, ich hatte so einen One-Pager-Gag gemacht mit deren Figuren. Das ist gut, One-Pager. Und die haben den dann genommen, die haben gesagt, die Idee war geil, so wie du eben hier einfach die Wahlpointe gedroppt hast,
habe ich da was gemacht und die haben gesagt, nehmen wir, hier ist ein Scheck und wenn du möchtest, gerne mehr.
Und ab da war ich im Profi-Autorum-Business. Und weil ich das so lange schon mache...
Wie viel Geld war das, der Scheck? Dein erster Scheck?
50 Mark.
50 Mark, aber das ist nicht so schlecht.
3000 Euro.
Ja, und hast du den noch an die Wand gehängt, den ersten Scheck? Wie bitte? den hast du noch an die Wand gehängt, den ersten Check?
Wie bitte?
Hast du den in die Wand gehängt, den ersten Check? Hast du den noch?
Ich hatte, also das ist leider, leider, leider bei einem, sag mal bei einem Bratten.
Bei dem großen Checkfeuer 1998, wo gesamte Checkbestände Deutschland zu verbrannt.
Er war eine Weitere, erinnert sich.
Das war eine harte Zeit.
Ich hatte so eine Kiste mit alten Briefen im Keller und dann war irgendwann da Regen, Rücklaufbecken und dann war alles nass und da habe ich nicht mehr. Aber ist auch egal. Aber ist das auch was, wo du raten würdest, Leute, die irgendwie auch in das Business wollen, einfach aggressiv ihre Sachen überall hinschicken und so lange in Nerven ist? Ich weiss, du hast diese Frank-Elstner-Geschichte, der hat sich immer wohl entdeckt. Wir sind hier durch die Tür gekommen, haben uns hingesetzt und haben einfach angefangen aufzunehmen. Haltet uns auf!
Nee, aber ich musste nie für irgendwas kämpfen. Ich wurde meistens gefragt, hast du nicht Bock, hier was zu machen?
Da habe ich gesagt, ja.
Entschuldigung, das war ja kein Kampf. Ich habe ja eine Zeichnung von mir im Bilden, das war ein Stückchen hingeschickt.
Ja, aber du hast aktiv, hast du den Willen gefasst und Initiative ergriffen?
Du auch.
Du sehst ihn hier, wenn du irgendwann mal die folgende drei Personen...
Nee, dein großes Ding war das, die Bewerbung für die Frank-Else-Mars-Verkehr.
Ja, aber ab dann war alles lawinenhaft, der Aufstieg ist auch eine schlechte Metapher eigentlich. Sitzt hier mit dem Mikro in der Socke drüber. Ein Rutschen auf der Aufstieg, ja, ja, komm. Was die Wahrheit ist. Es ist die Wahrheit. Wie bist du denn hier gelandet? Ich habe mich beworben, mehrere Male. Nee, ich habe mich einmal hier beworben. Mit so einem Speck-Skript oder was schief man damit? Ne, damals waren die BTF ja noch drei Leute, die irgendwie so ein Kölner Hinterhof, weiss ich nicht was, gemacht haben. Versuch, er schickt. Bitte? Versuch zu erklären, was ein Speck-Skript ist. Sockenmann hatte ich gedappt. Und da habe ich mich irgendwann beworben, dann ging die nicht unter, musste auf Englisch. Dann habe ich mich beworben und dann ging das irgendwann auch relativ einfach, weil es nicht so viele waren. Und da, es war auch nur ständische Aushilfe. Also da war ich noch als Praktikant. Irgendwann kam ich dann zum Schreiben, ganz easy, eigentlich. Aber eigentlich, ja, aber ich habe es eigentlich auch vorweg geplant. Am Schreibtisch habe ich mir so die Karriere eigentlich ausgemalt, ausgemalt, Unterschrift geübt. Mit Stern, mit Stern. Erstmal langsam anfangen als Praatikant bewerben und dann langsam von innen den Laden zerstören. Und bist du im Zeitplan? Bist du im Zeitplan? Voll, voll. Der jetzige Zeitpunkt habe ich eigentlich für 2017 geplant. Warum fangen die eigentlich jetzt erst mit Stand-Up an, das verstehe ich gar nicht. In welchem Alter kommt erster Bartwuchs? Wann hast du das geplant? 21, kam. Ach ja, hast du ja passend. Kam, 21, Bart. Warum wir jetzt erst mit Stand-Up anweisen, das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Ich habe mich, also, ich hätte diese Kunstform so ein bisschen, sehr guter Gag, sehr guter, kann man mal sagen, zwischen dir, erlobend erwähnen, dass es ein guter Gag war. Sie müssen noch so viel lernen. Wir haben beide, glaube ich, so ein bisschen das Gefühl gehabt, dass uns die Kunstform so ein bisschen abschreckt, vielleicht aber aus dem deutschen. Was hast du Angst gemacht? Nein, es ist Faulheit, fick dich, es ist einfach Faulheit. Nein, aber ich merke auch jetzt, dass ich mich am Wochenende halt nicht hinsetze, um ein Stand-Up-Programm zu schreiben, obwohl ich es müsste, weil wir einfach beide, nee, muss man erst mal sagen, wir können wesentlich weiter sein, wenn wir nicht so fucking faul wären. Ich sitze eigentlich den ganzen Tag dumm rum und mache gar nichts. Also muss ich jetzt echt mal sagen, also ich mache so gut wie nix. Ich gucke, dass ich jeden Tag einen Tweet raushau, so, und das war's. Das schaffe ich doch nicht. Dafür läuft es ganz gut, oder? Ja, aber ich könnte noch wesentlich mehr machen, wenn ich nicht so scheiße faul wäre, einfach so. Aber das ist es einfach. Muss man sagen, du hattest bei der Frank-Elster-Masterclass, hattest du ein Team, Kamerateam, professionelle Leute. Es wäre echt geil, wenn man nicht ununterbrochen über diesen Begriff lachen würde. Mich haben schon so viele Leute gefragt, so, ach, das gibt's wirklich, das ist kein Gangster. Ich hab das in einem Zeitungsartikel über dich gelesen. Er war auch in der fucking Comedy Masterclass hier, Stefan Theissel, der hier versucht, das so ein bisschen drunter zu spielen. Wir waren alle in der Masterclass, das verbindet uns, ja. Der einzige, der hier nicht in der Uli Stein Masterclass war, warst du mein Lieber. Das ist vollkommen richtig. Ich habe meine eigene Masterclass gegründet. Burn! Soll ich jetzt den Chatverlauf vorlesen? Lies es mal vor. Ach so, da sind wir immer noch. Also ich habe geschrieben eine Nachricht, die jeder gerne mal bekommen würde. Okay, ich habe richtig scheisse gebaut, richtig gross geschrieben, ich habe richtig scheisse gebaut, habe ich geschrieben.
Stefan antwortet mit Nein, nein, nein, nein, viermal nein.
Zweite Nachricht, nein, Alter.
Dritte Nachricht, was zur Hölle.
Ich schreibe, wie es aussieht, ist alles weg.
Stefan antwortet, und im Bad ist ein Tiger.
Stefan antwortet mit, hast du den Verstand verloren? Stefan weiter, kläre das morgen mal mit WordPress, das kann man bestimmt rückgängig machen. So, da sagt ihm ist das Schwarz zu. Schritt zurückgegangen, überlegt, was kann man machen. Immer einen Schritt zurückgehen, das Kunstwerk war da weg, bet betrachten. Im Fall war es ein Desaster. Stefan weiter, was hast du denn gemacht? Also er versucht schon noch ein bisschen die Fasson zu bewahren, so was ist passiert? Autographie und so, ihr gebt euch da schon noch Mühe, das ist alles alles. Absolut, das ist auch absolut recht. Großgeschrieben mit Punkten, alles. Ich habe geschrieben, WordPress ist eine Open Source Software, es ist nicht so, als man da anrufen könnte. Ach du, du musst es noch schlimmer, als ob ich den Scheiß gebaut habe.
Da hast du irgendwie noch drauf.
Am dich zu belehren.
Ich habe versucht, dir jede Hoffnung zu nehmen.
Es gibt so, nope, da gibt es keinen Russ. So ein belehrendes Arschloch zu sein, obwohl man den Mist gebaut hat.
Stefan antwortet, ja, ich komme nicht mehr rein.
Und jetzt, komplett in Caps, was hast du getan?
Ich antworte, ich habe aus Versehen das gesamte WordPress-Blog überschrieben.
Stefan, ich fasse es nicht.
Der Fall liegt am Boden.
Ich wieder, okay, das ist wirklich Worst Case gerade.
Auch iTunes geht nicht mehr.
Das wäre wirklich komplett.
Stefan, natürlich nicht, unsere Seite ist weg, du hast alles gelöscht.
Könnt ihr mir einen Gefallen tun?
Lasst mal Klassikradio laufen und lest das Click dazu vor. Ich glaube, dass es richtig dramatisch kommt. Das finde ich auch nicht schlecht, das finde ich eine gute Idee. Ich werde alles neu hochladen, der Feed sollte eigentlich noch stehen, unwiederbringlich sind nur die Kommentare weg. Aber tatsächlich muss man letztlich sagen, ich habe innerhalb von zwei Stunden die gesamte Seite rekonstruiert, alle Seiten hochgeladen, alle Kommentare wiedergefunden und neu gepostet. Das ist doch in irgendeiner Klaue. Aber das, was ich eben als mein Werk bezeichnet habe, ist in zwei Stunden zu reparieren. Ja, aber das hat auf mich gewundert. Ich weiß nicht, ob das für mich spricht. Das alles, was ich, wo ich denke, du hast wirklich was geleistet in diesem Jahr, ist in zwei Stunden zu rekonstruieren. Das war ja nicht weg und die Kommentare waren ja nicht von dir. Die waren nicht von dir. Nee, und hat aber dazu geführt, dass er die ganze Seite neu hochladen musste, die ganzen Folgen. Und Leute haben halt komplett, du hast ein komplettes Datenvolumen für den ganzen Monat geklaut, weil die ganzen Folgen wegkamen. Ja, weil alle, nur mal alles, gerade in der Folgen. Und Leute haben geschrieben, ja danke Podcast-Dufo. Ja, ja, das tut mir auch echt leid. Also da, ich werde nochmal ein offizielles Charme-Video machen, dass ich mich schäme für alles, was geschehen ist. Oder beweis einfach das Geld zurück. Ihr habt ja schon. Wir haben schon, wir haben nichts mehr. Nee, gar nicht, ist alles versoffen.
Jetzt gehen wir langsam wieder für unseren Trip nächste Woche zu den Rocket Beans.
Wir sind nächste Woche in Hamburg bei den Rocket Beans und dafür sammeln wir jetzt
wieder.
Also wir fahren nicht dahin, wir fahren nicht dahin, aber wir sammeln Geld.
Nee, wir fahren nicht dahin.
Wir sammeln einfach Geld.
Noch ein paar Highlights von Stefan aus dem Monolog.
Wie zum Teufel geht das?
Und dann komplett in Caps geschrieben. Und warum an dem Tag, an dem Luke Mockridge uns geteilt hat, was eine berechtigte Frage ist tatsächlich, der Tag, an dem wir am meisten Traffic hast und auch noch, ich glaube, ich war noch nie so wütend. Ja, aber es ist am Ende, also die Botschaft ist auch eine gute und es ist alles wieder ausgegangen, also wenn ihr fest genug an euch glaubt und alle Folgen noch auf der Festplatte irgendwo rumliegen hat, dann kann man alles schaffen. Klar, man merkt, also die eigentliche Lehre, die wir hieraus ziehen, ist ja Freundschaft. Weil man merkt ja in diesem Dialog, dass ihr, na klar, ihr seid Freunde, denn es bleibt eigentlich richtige Beleidigungen bleiben aus, Schuldzuweisungen auch nicht. Und hier wird sich berührt, zu Recht, noch über dem Tisch, ich bin erstaunt, ehrlich gesagt. Ja, unterm Tisch sind ganz andere Sachen. Ja, und ihr seid färg miteinander umgegangen und habt das Problem gelöst und es war auch klar, es ist nicht weg. Aber Stefan und ich, wir haben uns, glaube ich, noch nie gestritten und wir streiten uns noch nicht. Ich glaube, wir sind beide Menschen, die sich nicht streiten, wir sind, glaube ich, an der Oberfläche sehr professionell. Wir sind, glaube ich, an der Oberfläche sehr professionell. Ne, wir nehmen beide direkt so eine Meta-Ebene ein, so eine Folieperspektive und gucken darauf, was gerade passiert ist und das ist glaube ich auch bei uns allen so. Du malst es halt und wir denken halt darüber nach, ob das passen muss, was uns wurde. Du bist der Maler unter uns, du bist halt der bildliche Typ. Man muss ja tatsächlich auch bei so kreativen Berufen oft so von seiner eigenen Meinung auch so einen Schritt zurücknehmen. Ich würde sagen, ich habe keine eigene Meinung. Ja, aber nein, ohne Scheiß, ich habe keine Meinung. Das ist ein großes Problem. Ich habe auch im Unterricht, aber ich bin hier noch zur Uni, und dann Leute regen sich auf neben mir. Und ich habe mir, wo, was ist los, was ist gerade los? Ich habe dir nur die Brüste gekriegt, wo geht, was mal auf? Welche Meinung nehme ich an, damit die Situation jetzt am lustigsten ist? Das ist natürlich ziemlich schlecht, wenn du Stand-up machen willst, weil du brauchst eine Haltung zu irgendwas. Eine Haltung ist was anderes als Meinung. Die denke ich mir aus, um lustig zu sein. Natürlich habe ich eine Meinung, ich habe einen gewissen Norm- und Werte-Grundsatz, den jeder von uns haben sollte, glaube ich, auch in der richtigen Richtung. Aber ich nehme nicht gerne... Zum Beispiel 37 Jahre, keine Fotos von sich schicken, wenn man neun ist. Ach so, das Welche Nicht habe ich damals vergessen.
Aber ich glaube, dass tatsächlich auch, weil ich weiß nur von Freunden, die Design studiert haben, die gesagt haben, der Professor hat bei denen eine der ersten Vorlesungen gesagt, okay, das wird jetzt eine Weile dauern, das wird jetzt ein halbes Jahr, ein Semester, zwei Semester dauern, aber ich werde euch einfach fucking austreiben, dass ihr eure Arbeit in irgendeiner Weise mit euch verbindet und einfach, wenn ich sage, das ist scheisse, dass ihr das nicht mit euch verbindet, sondern dass ihr einfach unterscheiden müsst zwischen eurem Werk und euch selber und einfach, dass die Meinung, die ihr zu wissen, Dinge habt, einfach nichts mit euch zu tun haben und einfach euch davon trennt. Das ist aber bei Texten genauso. Als ich angefangen habe zu schreiben, habe ich Texte abgegeben und sie wurden fertig gemacht oder umgeschrieben und ich war einfach aufgelöst und war einfach fertig damit, ich konnte damit gar nicht umgehen. Also wenn jemand sagt, dein Text ist scheisse, dass du das nicht auf dich beziehst, sondern auch einfach drüber guckst und sagst, okay, wo können wir Dinge verbessern. Das habe ich ja auch gemacht, als ich mit 14 angefangen habe, diese ersten Geschichten zu schreiben, dann ist der eine Autor da auch drüber und hat das im Grunde gekürzt, gerafft, gesagt, hier läuft die Schicht, das erzählt nichts, das geht in keine Richtung. und das hat mir total geholfen. Also wenn man diese Kritik annimmt, ist das ja super, aber wie ist denn das beim Grafikdesign, du musst ja trotzdem irgendwie, also vielleicht kenne ich mich da einfach überhaupt null aus.
Aber du musst eine gewisse Objektivität zu deiner Arbeit herstellen. Na klar.
Dass wenn der sagt, das ist scheisse, dass du nicht sagst, ey du dummer Arschloch irgendwie, du hast das beleidigt.
Ach so, du musst das trennen von dir als Person.
Sondern dass du halt dann sagst, okay, was ist daran scheisse, so, nee, aber ich glaube, das ist ja auch eine Charaktereigenschaft, die sich dann ja auch an dein Leben überträgt, dass du halt dann sagst, wenn jemand irgendwie zu dir sagt, du hast scheiße gebaut, dass du das dann irgendwie versucht, rationaler, problemorientierter zu gucken. Im besten Fall. Ich finde es ganz interessant, ihr habt ja auch neulich darüber gesprochen, dass ihr auf dem Comedypreis gewesen seid und wie uninteressant ihr eigentlich die Veranstaltung gefunden habt. Ja. Ich bin ja auch schon ein paar Jahre lang da gewesen und habe genau, ja, ich bin vor zehn Jahren das erste Mal da. Wie kommst du denn auf einen Comedypreis? Ich war schon mal sauer, kann ich nicht mehr. Ich habe eine sehr gute Freundin, die aus dem Comedy-Business kommt und die hat mich mitgegangen. Und die hat die Catering-Tür offen gelassen hinten in der Küche. Und dann bin ich selbst eingeladen worden, weil ich da mit Brainpool gearbeitet habe. 2007 habe ich ja angefangen mit Brainpool, mein Spaß zu tun gehabt, ihr redet nicht davon. Und dann war ich da mit einmal und ich habe mir da wirklich viel von versprochen, weil ich irgendwie wusste.
Man denkt, es ist die lustigste Veranstaltung Deutschlands, weil es der Comedypreis. Weil ich wollte, dass ich mit dem, was ich da mache, was ja auch Humor ist, in irgendeiner Form Bühnenkrempel mache und habe gedacht, ich muss mir Stand-Up-Komediens kennenlernen und habe gedacht, das wäre in irgendeiner Form eine Rampe. Aber ich habe da zwar Leute kennengelernt, aber meistens waren das Fernsehmacher und dann waren das auch noch so Fernsehmacher, wo ich dachte, oh, so stelle ich mir immer vor, dass Fernsehmacher sind, aber das möchte ich alles gar nicht und es ist dann ganz anders gekommen. Ich habe wirklich über direkte Kontakte mit, eigentlich war es dann Markus Barth und der, der mich dann so ein bisschen damit reingeholt hat und dann habe ich so mitgekriegt, wie man das macht, so auf einer Bühne stehen und Zeug erzählen. Aber ich fand halt auch, dass die Leute, mit denen man sich unterhält, selten komisch sind, selten reflektiert sind und das als Angriff verstehen, wenn man ihre Arbeit nicht mag. Und das war mir sofort klar, als Flo und Dieter geschrieben hat, dass er Rote hasst. Ja, aber da ist mir wichtig, dass du das auch nicht nur auf deine Arbeit beziehst, sondern auch wirklich auf dich als Person. Weil ich meinte, die Rote Comics, die sind mir scheißegal, das ist für mich niederträchtige, entartete Kunst, das ist mir scheissegal. Mir geht es um dich als Person, das ist halt irgendwie mir schon wichtig, dass du weißt, dass ich dich persönlich auch echt nicht so gut finde. Ja, das ist gut. Schön, das war noch ein schöner Schluss heute. Nein! Nein, ich wollte noch, ich kann es, ich habe noch eine Gag-Idee, vielleicht kannst du da was draus machen. Oh nein, über diese Flur und die Gag-Idee würde ich mich im Keil mehr schlicken. Zieh, wir nehmen deine Hose wieder. Okay. Nee, zieh. Also ein Hund sagt, statt Alarmstufe rot, sagt er Alarmstufe etwas dunkleres grau. Das ist der Ursprungsgag, kann man da was draus machen. Hast du auch mal das Tweet rausgehauen irgendwann? Nee, ich hab nur mal im Casino, ich setze alles auf Grau.
Hund im Casino.
Ja, aber kann man da was mitmachen?
Also das steht jetzt mal als Gag-Ide.
Warum fragst du dieses Scheisse? Natürlich kann man da was mitmachen, das weißt du doch selbst.
Ja, aber mir fehlt der Rahmen.
Regeln sind doch die gleichen, wie wenn du einen Sketch draus machen würdest.
Weißt du, was der Grund ist? Er will diesen Gag irgendwie in diesem Podcast platzieren, und er verpackt es als Frage, weil er sonst keine Chance hat, in dieser Folge den Gag zu platzieren.
Nein, wenn ich gewusst hätte, wie ich den Gag verpacke, hätte ich ihn als Tweet rausgehauen, weil meine Tweets sind mir wesentlich wichtiger als ihr beiden. Ich weiß nicht den Kontext, ich sehe immer irgendwie, weil was, in welcher Situation würde ein Hund sagen, Alarmstufe Rot? Feuerwehrhund. Ja, oder ich sehe ihn an irgendeinem Pult sitzen, eine Überwachung mit Kameras und sieht irgendwas und brüllt das laut in ein Mikro rein, das kann man machen. Polizeihund. Ah, okay. Aber du weißt, das ist ja wie beim Stand-up, du musst die Leute erstmal abholen. Und das musst du, wo du halt da die Rampe aufbaust zu der Punchline. Aber die abholen, da habe ich gesagt, ich habe kein Auto. Ja, danke. Und da musst du halt irgendwie einen Raum erschaffen, wo du als Leser sofort weißt, ah, da bin ich und deswegen ruft er das. Ich weiß nicht, warum man jetzt Alarmstufe Rot sagen müsste, er könnte ja auch in irgendeiner anderen, aber ich habe jetzt so, diese Hunde können keine Farben sehen, Gags auch schon zu oft gesehen, also den finde ich jetzt persönlich ein bisschen ausgelutscht, aber nicht schlecht gedacht. Ich finde es so gut, dass vorhin das Gag sehen wir, alle von allen Gästen einfach nur fertig gemacht werden, aber auch immer alle versuchen, so nett zu sein und sachlich zu bleiben, aber im Grunde sagen sie alle nur andere Worte für, nee, der gefällt mir nicht, aber die überschreiben es aber alle Gäste auf ihre nette Art umschreiben, das ist immer, dass sie das scheiße finden. Das finde ich so nett, das finde ich so nett. Ich will so kleiner, nice. Das Gespräch funktioniert gerade nicht, wollen wir vielleicht nicht mit den Router neu starten? Man muss fairerweise sagen, dass du ja bis jetzt noch kein Gag angekommen hast. Leute, da kommt ja gar nichts, Router, Router, ach ey, fickt euch. Das ist das Fishing for Compliments, was ich nicht will. Das ist doch scheisse, ey! Ich hab mir hier drei Gags vorbereitet, und das, dass man einfach mal sagt, weil du immer von wegen, ich lass dich hängen mit deinen Scheissporten, wo man auch wirklich mal sagt, ich hab mich so schon hundertmal gehört. Ja. Kotz mich an, ey! Komm, immer gut in so einem Podcast Raum. Du musst den Raum nutzen, das ist ein Gefühl, wo ist der jetzt wirklich rausge raus? Er muss manchmal die Kamera manchmal ausblenden. Er weiß nicht genau, dass er nur gerade auf einer auditiven Ebene funktioniert. Aber jetzt haben wir noch ein bisschen Zeit für uns. Jetzt haben wir noch ein bisschen Zeit darüber. Wie hat der noch mal meinen... Das ist mir eh der Sympathische. Der Sketch, den ich gemalt habe. Wie hat der dir noch mal gefallen? Okay, er ist wieder zurück. Okay, er ist wieder zurück. Okay, er ist wieder da. Er ist wieder da. Nein, komm Florentin. Komm zurück Florentin. Jetzt sei nicht so. Ja, wir wollten ja gerade uns unterhalten, oder? Wir wollten uns gerade nett unterhalten. Ich habe ganz tolle Fragen für dich vorbereitet, zum Beispiel, du führst ein idyllisches Fernsehleben, Familienleben, alle Comedians haben ein Defizit. Ey, ich habe echt die Fragen von Luggenmock, das ist kein Scherz, ich habe die alle noch hier, und ich überlege gerade, aber dieses Defizit-Ding finde ich ganz interessant. So, es heißt ja, das Humor immer von so Wovor läufst du eigentlich weg? Wovor, was ist dein, wo ist dein Haken? Was ist dein Haken? Du musst darauf antworten. Warum hast du damals, als du vierzehn warst, warum bist du nicht mit Bernie, Andrea und Carsten raus zum Fussballspiel gegangen, sondern hast dich alleine mit Nobby, warum hast du dich alleine zuhause eingeschlossen und hast Bilder gemalt, Bilder von Mädchen gemalt, weil es mich, das war noch früher, wir haben eine Comic-Redaktion sogar gegründet. Norberts Vater hat Wintergärten verkauft und hatte ein Büro, in dem er diese Kaufverträge abgewickelt hat. Wenn er nicht da war, haben wir uns ins Büro gesetzt, so getan, als wären wir eine Comic-Redaktion. Haben genau wie du eben so getan, als wenn wir telefonieren mit Leuten und sagen, ah ja, die neuen Seiten kommen gleich und jetzt machen wir doch die Witze und die Kreuzworträtsel und dann haben wir uns da Geschichten ausgedacht, Comics gezeichnet. Das habe ich auch sehr aufgemacht, aber jetzt nicht in diesem Nerd-Kosmos, wo du was bist, auf den ich nicht folgen will. Und mir war vollkommen klar, dass das irgendwann Realität wird, dass das mein Alltag sein wird, in irgendeiner Form mit Redaktionen zu sprechen und denen Zeug abzuliefern und naja. Aber du arbeitest ja viel alleine, oder? Ich denke mir, dein Arbeitsfeld besteht hauptsächlich aus dir und einem weissen Blatt Papier. Ne, und deiner ganzen Redaktion. Ne, sondern dann erzähl, wie es wirklich ist. Ralpaharathy. Alter, Leute, du kotzt mich an. Also für den Fall, dass ihr die Antwort wirklich haben möchtet. Ich möchte gerne haben. Ich mache ja viele Videos und die mache ich zusammen mit dem Animator. Ja, aber auch deine Cartoons. Da ist doch hauptsächlich die Dinge von dir. Das heißt, du bist dann da, schließt dich zu Hause ein oder läufst dann nebenbei der Fernseher oder wie arbeitest du? Genau so, genau so. Aber zum Beispiel zum Thema Kreativität. Don Draper hat tatsächlich was gesagt, also der Hauptfigur aus der Serie Madman, der in einer Werbeagentur arbeitet, der hat gesagt, mit Ideen funktioniert es immer gleich, du musst bis zum Ende des Tages eine Idee haben und die erste Hälfte des Tages arbeitest du intensiv, brainstormst, schreibst Sachen auf, aber es kommt nichts dabei raus, dann gibst du auf, fängst an, dich zu betrinken und dann irgendwann, wenn du sowieso denkst, ich schaffe die Deadline sowieso nicht, kommt irgendwann von ganz allein die Idee und du hast die Idee. Also Hälfte des Tages hart arbeiten und andere Hälfte des Tages aufgehen, Depression, weinen, Flucht nach vorne, Alkoholismus, Drogenkonsum und Menstruation, Masturbation, je nachdem, wo man gerade mehr Lust drauf hat und dann kommt von alleine irgendwann die Idee. Hast du das auch erfahren oder arbeit du anders als eine ausgedachte figure aus einer serie also nah dran ist auf jeden fall dass ich die deadline brauche wenn ich mir nicht selbst sage das muss dann fertig sein oder ich denke ich habe jetzt drei oder vier tage keinen neuen cartoon auf der seite gemacht dann drückt das so sehr bei mir im Schädel dass ich denke da muss ich jetzt auf jeden fall was neues raushauen und das weiß, ich will Donnerstag... Was brauchst du daran? Brauchst du das Ventil oder brauchst du die Anerkennung von Leuten? Nein, ich brauche den Zeitdruck, um abliefern zu können, weil das kenne ich nicht anders, weil ich... Aber du hast ja keinen Druck, den machst du dir ja selber. Aber du fühlst dich ja schlecht, wenn du nichts machst, ne? Ja, aber warum? Also schlecht nicht, aber... Was gibt dir das? Was gibt dir das, wo du das ab... das ist gerade Kreuzverhör mässig... Aber was gibt dir das? Also warum machst du dir selber den Druck, was zu veröffentlichen, was veröffentlichen zu wollen? Ich sehe mich selbst als Fan, also wenn ich denke, also bestes Beispiel ist wieder Joscha, nicht lustig. Ich finde es total schade, wenn ich da, mei und lai, es ist ja momentan so, wenn da so wenig nachkommt. Ja, das ist echt schade, aber kannst du da nicht mal mit ihm reden, dass da irgendwie mehr kommt von ihm oder so? Ja, das ist eine gute Idee, das mache ich mal. Kannst du dich mal ein bisschen zurücknehmen und ihm ein bisschen mehr Raum geben? Genau, und so sehe ich das und ich denke mir immer, wenn da Leute sind, denen das ja offensichtlich auch gut gefällt, dann will ich auch nachliefern. Und ich finde es einfach total schön, wenn ein Künstler nicht nur eine Qualität hält, sondern eben auch einfach viel produziert, wenn das geht. Also wenn es nach mir ginge, könnte zum Beispiel, ich bin wirklich wenig Fanboy von vielen Sachen, aber Olli Schulz zum Beispiel könnte meinetwegen einfach gerne alle halbe Jahre ein Album raushauen. Finde ich total geil. Würde aber dann vielleicht weniger Olli Schulz werden, weil es auch zu Olli Schulz wird, dass er weniger produziert. Das wäre eben meine Idealvorstellung, weil ich mir einfach wünsche oder keine Ahnung, dass es eben endlich eine neue Staffel von irgendwas gibt, was ich eben auch super finde, dass ich die endlich gucken kann. Und ja, das passiert halt nicht immer, weil es eben auch einfach nicht geht. Ich habe mich neulich gefragt, worüber haben Menschen eigentlich geredet, bevor es Serien gab. Das hast du noch, ja genau, in dem Podcast. Hab ich das auch mal hier gemacht. Damn it, ey. Und was haben die gemacht auf Partys, als es noch keine Smartphones gab und man nicht... Ich finde es interessant, dass wir 38 Stunden lang jetzt schon geredet haben und davon vielleicht 15 Minuten über Serien gesprochen haben. Ansonsten eigentlich nur über sprechende Bäume und den Tod
in Personen. Ja, genau. Ich finde, wir haben sehr wenig
über Serien gesprochen. Aber
trotzdem interessant. Also man redet ja,
also der kleinste gemeinsame
Nenner sind wirklich Serien mit Leuten,
mit denen ich abends rede.
Naja, aber da es so wahnsinnig viele Serien
gibt, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, merke ich.
Es wird immer komplizierter, sich auf
einen Serie zu einigen, die alle gesehen haben, weil es mittlerweile zu viele Serien gibt. Aber ich finde es interessant, was für eine Der Fordergrund ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, Wahrscheinlichkeit, merke ich. Es wird auch immer komplizierter, sich eine Serie auf eine Serie zu einigen, die alle gesehen haben, weil es mittlerweile zu viele Serien gibt, aber ich finde es interessant, was war denn da vorher der kleinste gemeinsame, weil Wetter, Sport, Serien ist das Neue. Sport auf jeden Fall, Politik. Ja genau, und Serien nimmt das Ganze so ein bisschen ein. Außerdem, ich glaube, das siehst du so sehr in deinem Kosmos. Ich glaube, es wird immer noch genauso viel über Politik und Sport gesprochen wie sonst auch, nur wir quatschen eben, also früher, Serien gab es ja immer, nicht in dieser Dichte und nicht diese Qualität vielleicht, aber du konntest dich natürlich auch vor 20 Jahren mindestens über die Simpsons unterhalten, die neue Folge, oder davor, keine Ahnung, was es da noch gegeben hat, es gab immer Serien, und wenn es der Tatort war, ist ja auch eine Serie. Also mal ganz kurz, es gibt Simpsons, Modern Simpsons, Family Guy, Rick and Morty, ja, wahnsinnig tolle Sachen, Bojack Horseman. Warum gibt es sowas nicht in Deutschland? Und warum arbeitest du dich aktiv daran, dass es sowas magisch war? Vor allem, ganz kurz nochmal, warum es was anderes ist als zum Beispiel eine andere Comedy-Serie, du kannst alles machen. Ein Comic erlaubt dir alles. Echt? Wollte ich kurz nochmal sagen. Das ist, glaube ich, ganz gut, dass du ihm das sagst.
Wollte ich dir noch mal erklären.
Also, falls du denkst, du hast irgendwie Fesseln im Kopf oder so, muss nicht sein. Schon verstanden. Leute müssen nicht auf dem Boden stehen, du kannst sie auch fliegen lassen, Menschen. Also, das gibt es nicht in Deutschland, weil TV-Sender das konsequent verhindern. Sie verstehen es nicht. Why? Ja, also ich behaupte nicht, dass also Simpsons
ist oder war genial, kann man sich jetzt darüber streiten, wohin das jetzt gegangen ist. Wann wurde es scheisse? Welche Staffel? Ich habe aber jetzt schon noch wirklich lange nichts mehr geguckt, ich bin irgendwie so bei der achten raus. Neunte, für mich die neunte. High five. Geil. Nach der neunten wurde Simpsons scheiße.
Es ist so, dass also Family Guy zum Beispiel, finde ich, also die Gags finde ich teilweise
brillant, es gibt wunderbare Momente, aber die haben halt vom Storytelling her niemals das erreicht, was Simpsons hatte, haben die auch nie versucht.
Rick and Morty ist jetzt wieder was, und jetzt kommt man natürlich in völligen Nerdtalk hier, ich weiß nicht mehr, ob du das kennst, aber hast du mal gesehen, worauf das basiert, was so der erste Trickfilm war, der die Basis geliefert hat für Rick and Morty? Es gibt auf Vimeo, warte, wie heißt es denn da? Es ist wirklich eine Parodie auf Zurück in die Zukunft, auf Doc Brown und Marty. Und es ist so ein drei Minuten grottenschlecht animiert, richtig scheisse. Der ist unglaublich sexuell, also permanent sieht man blutige Hoden und einen Penis. Unterbrochen. Ja, ja, und es ist so eine Pädobeziehung zwischen diesem Jungen und diesem alten Wissenschaftler. Aber viele Charakterzüge, also erstmal die Stimmen sind schon identisch wie in der Serie, und so diese ganze Dynamik zwischen den beiden, die ist schon da. Ansonsten hat dieser drei Minuten nichts von dem, was aus dieser Serie geworden ist. So, jetzt hat irgendein Fernsehmacher, ich glaube einer der Erfinder von, wie heißt diese Serie, wo die alle zusammen in dieser Volkshochschule sitzen? Community. Ja genau. Dan Harmon wahrscheinlich. Genau, einer von den Community-Machern hat das gesehen, hat gesagt, wie geil ist das denn, mit dem Typen muss ich mich treffen. Der hat halt irgendwas darin gesehen. Und diese Visionäre fehlen in Deutschland. Diese Visionäre fehlen in Deutschland und es gibt vor allem in Deutschland Leute, die erkennen, dass Animation nicht automatisch Kinderkram ist. Ihr wisst, dass eigentlich, ja, selbst die Leute, mit jedem, mit dem du dich auf einen Comedypreis in der Hälfte, will wahrscheinlich auch sagen, dass es Super-Comedy ist, aber für die Fernsehmacher ist es Trickfilm. Und Trickfilm ist nun mal Kinderfernsehen oder zumindest Familienunterhaltung, weil eins ist nun mal auch ein Problem, es ist sehr teuer. Ja, aber ganz kurz, sorry, was ich immer so komisch finde, dass man auf solche Fragen, warum gibt es in Deutschland so etwas nicht immer so einfache Fragen findet, so dieses Antworten dazu, das kann doch nicht wahr sein, so einfache Antworten finden, das kann doch nicht wahr sein, ich meine, die arbeiten doch beim Fernsehen, die müssen doch auch mitbekommen haben, dass es Bojack Horseman, Archer, ja, wahnsinnig, dass es Sachen gibt. Habt ihr schon mal woanders gearbeitet als hier für Jan und für BDF? Dann wüsstest du, dass das leider so ist, die haben keine Ahnung. Also außerhalb von dem, was hier geschieht, und hier passieren wunderbare Sachen, haben viele Menschen von Comedy, finde ich, keine Ahnung und sehen diesen Zusammenhang nicht, dass man eben in animierter Form brillante Comedy erschaffen kann, geile Geschichten erzählen kann, Möglichkeiten hat, die man sonst nicht hat und für die ist das eben Familienunterhaltung und du musst auch bei einem animierten Spielfilm musst du dafür sorgen, dass am besten die unter sechsjährigen noch mit rein können, damit es halt ein guter Familienfilm ist. Das ist ja auch teuer. Also wenn du einen animierten Kinofilm hast, der kostet halt ab sieben, acht, neun Millionen aufwärts. Ja, aber ich meine, man kann ja auch South Park machen. Ich meine, es ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass man irgendwie unbedingt jetzt das Rad neu erfinden muss, aber es ist ja... South Park lebt aber von vielen anderen Sachen. Das ist ja nun mal einfach so an eine erwachsene Zielgruppe dafür produziert. Lass uns doch einfach mal einen Piloten schreiben für so eine Serie. Ich werde sofort dabei. Ich werde sofort dabei. Weißt du, in Amerika gibt es halt auch so Sachen wie Adult Swim, halt dieser Sender, auf dem Rick and Morty läuft, wo halt Sachen Eric Andre Show, Fish Center, wo halt so fucking weirde, crazy Sachen laufen, halt auch primär Internet natürlich und so und die sich da einfach so diese Nische, die sich auch drauf verschrieben haben, wir machen den abgefahren so, wir sind scheiss der Welt und sowas kannst du halt hier auch komplett vergessen. Ja, aber nee, es gibt aber Rocket Beans TV oder so, wo man einfach, wenn man ein bisschen was selber in die Hand nimmt, theoretisch mal eine Plattform hätte. Und man muss es ja auch nicht so aufwendig produzieren. Also eine Sache, warum Joschas Projekt zum Beispiel einfach so lange braucht, ist, weil er animationstechnisch einen Anspruch hat, den ich nicht habe. Ich sage mir, das muss nicht, ich muss nicht die 24 Zwischenphasen haben in dieser Bewegung, ich brauche die nicht. Wenn der sich von da nach da dreht, dann kann das Gesicht ruhig einmal so klack machen, weil es nichts erzählt. Und wenn die Geschichte sich entwickelt, wenn ich der Figur folgen möchte, weil ich die interessant finde und wenn die Pointe geil ist, dann ist es mir einfach egal, wenn die Animation, sag ich mal, eine 3- ist oder sag mal eine 3+. Bei Joscha muss das alles eine 1 sein. Und damit es richtig geil ausseht, ist es einfach enorm teuer. Und man kann sowas auch günstiger machen. Das erarbeitet man sich ja. Also man erarbeitet sich die Qualität, auch gerade visuelle Qualität bei der Animation, das geht sich auch einfach über Zeit. Wenn du halt anfängst, gute Sachen zu schreiben, dann kann es am Anfang auch ein bisschen scheisser aussehen, wenn es auch so die Idee gut ist und so, da kannst du damit ja auch schon Leute überzeugen.
Schau dir auf YouTube sowas wie die ASDF-Movies an oder so, halt auch total krude, aber halt einfach durch einen einmaligen Humor gezeigt. Oder ich weiss, es ist verrückt, aber schau dir meine Sachen an, die sind ja auch mega simpel eigentlich. Ja, oder schau dir halt einfach was von Uli Steiner. Die hört schon sauer an, ich meine, die machen das schon gut. Aber die funktionieren eben auch und ich habe es ja selbst nicht gewusst oder geglaubt, dass das dann so viele Millionen Menschen irgendwann sehen werden, aber es funktioniert ja und es reicht, um die Geschichte zu erzählen. Aber du sagst immer, man muss weirden geilen Scheiß erzählen können. Tatsächlich finde ich gerade auch bei diesen Adult Swim Sachen, also im Kern haben die interessante Figuren und Geschichten, bei denen man dranbleibt. Auch Rick und Morty sind einfach toll erzählt Geschichte und sehr emotionales Zeug. Absolut, aber vor allem... Mich interessiert immer, wie stehen die zueinander, wie geht das aus? Und ich habe da manchmal auch Gänsehaut, weil ich denke, wow, das haben die wirklich in Folge 1 schon gewusst, dass das hier wieder auftaucht. Das ist einfach toll geschrieben. Ja, und vor allem, es ist halt auch dieser unglaubliche Meta-Humor. Also der ist bei Rick and Morty, glaube ich, extrem. Ich glaube, es geht nicht mehr Meta als Rick and Morty. Also Community war schon wahnsinnig Meta. Aber nicht nur, es funktioniert auch. Ja klar, aber ganz kurz, da hast du auch so ein, du setzt beim Zuschauer so ein wahnsinniges Verständnis von Storytelling und von, oh, ich sehe das Ganze als ein Produkt an. Also zum Beispiel ist eine Folge Rick and Morty, die gehen ja immer auf ein Abenteuer und der Wissenschaftler, der Opa ist immer. Das ist die Prämisse. Coole Geschichte. Rick und Morty gehen auf ein Abente. Du hattest mich bei Abenteuer. Du hattest mich bei Abenteuer. Aber Rick, also der Wissenschaftler, ist immer der, der sozusagen Morty ins Verderben mitreißt. Und in einer Folge sagt mal Morty, nee, ich will heute mal der Chef sein. Und dann sagt Rick, okay, dann machen wir jetzt mal ein Abenteuer wie du, aber wenn es scheiße ist, wenn es langweilig ist, dann bin ich wieder der Chef. Und dann geht es in der Sendung, in der Folge nur darum, wird das Abenteuer spannend und lustig und interessant. Das heißt, die Serie stellt sich selber den Auftrag, so von wegen, schaffen es die Figuren, jetzt eine interessante Folge zu machen und schaffen sie es das interessante Ding. Und das ist so meta, und dann benutzen sie auch ständig so Begriffe, so Call to Adventure und als muss das passieren und das und das ist so wahnsinnig meta und so wahnsinnig mit dem Augenzwinger und es nimmt den Zuschauer so wahnsinnig ernst. Das funktioniert nur in einer sehr, sehr erwachsenen Unterhaltungsszene, glaube ich. Und das ist für uns da drin, aber die Geschichte funktioniert trotzdem als Dobby. Absolut. Du hast immer noch, es tauchen interessante Charaktere auf, es ist cool animiert, die Hintergründe sind geil gezeichnet, du hast permanent das Gefühl, du wirst wirklich gut unterhalten, das heißt, du hast das da drin. Das hast du ja auch ganz oft in einem guten Pixar-Film drin. Da gibt es ja auch immer irgendeine Ebene, die für den Erwachsenen interessant ist, dann ist geile Slapstick-Comedy drin, es sind tolle Bilder, die sich lohnen, dafür ins Kino zu gehen, und so sollte eigentlich Unterhaltung immer funktionieren. Ja, ganz kurz eine Anmerkung, es läuft gerade im Kino, alles steht Koff inside out, und es ist so ein unfassbar fucking guter Film, ich will nur ganz kurz anreißen, schaut euch an, der ist unglaublich gut. Ich habe ihn gesehen. Alter, holy shit, ey, ich dachte mir, wie kann man so kreativ sein? Also diese Prämisse, es spielt sich alles in die Gefühle eines Mädchens, sind die Hauptfiguren und es ist alles eine riesengroße Metapher, dieser gesamte Film.
Irgendwie, die haben dann so kleine Glaskugeln, die stehen für Erinnerungen, bla bla bla, wahnsinnig gute Ideen und du denkst.
Das abstrakte Denken?
Ja, das abstrakte Denken und das ist so eine Welt, die immer weiter aufgedenkt ist, okay, jetzt gehen sie ins Unterbewusstsein, mein Gott, was für eine geile Idee, so da sind die ganzen schlummernden, tiefen Dinge, und es geht immer weiter und weiter und weiter und es ist unglaublich kreativ und das ist egal, schaut euch einfach an, aber sowas, solche Story-Ideen und sowas wie... Und die könntest du nicht in Deutschland machen, weil, glaube ich, hier die Produzenten sitzen und sagen würden, was, das ist doch viel zu psychologisch und wer soll das interessieren, wir brauchen auf jeden Fall eine Verfolgungsjagd und letztendlich wird da einfach eine Geschichte erzählt.
Ich habe ja nichts gegen eine Verfolgungsjagd, da sind ja auch Action-Elemente drin, damit die Kinder es verstehen, aber es sind auch wirklich gute Gags drin und gute Themen, die man auch als Ratschner versteht.
Danach fehlt da jetzt ein geschultes Unterhaltungspersonal in den oberen Chefetagen in Deutschland, weil das ist ja genau das gleiche, bei Pixar hat er diesen, wie hies er, Lasseter. Genau, der einfach, ich habe so einen Artikel gelesen, wo er einfach alle das Bauchgefühl von ihm abfeiern.
Und der einfach nur wegen seines Bauchgefühls, seiner Intuition, die kann er manchmal nicht mal begründen,
aber alles, was er sagt, wird der Film scheiße, wird er scheiße, er hat alles vorhergesagt.
Und Cast zweifelte furchtbar, wurde auch furchtbar, stand er auch wirklich hinter. Ja, den hat er aber auch für sich gemacht.
Und sie haben Geld damit verdient, das ist eine Ahnung.
Ja, gut, das sind andere Sachen, aber er hat aber auch wirklich immer gesagt, Toy Story hat er glaube ich auch die erste, die erste gemacht, meine ich. Ja, ja, klar. Und er hat einfach dieses Gefühl, wo die irgendwann mal rausgefunden haben, okay, das ist ein Typ, auf den wir uns verlassen können. Das ist wie so das Orakel von Delphi. Ja, genau. So ab dem dritten Erfolgsfilm denkt man da wahrscheinlich auch, der kann das. Ja, und das ist einfach dieses Bauchgefühl, diese Intuition, die aber entsteht, wenn halt über Jahre geiler Unterhalt und Shit produziert wird.
Aber ich muss dazu sagen, die Basis für all das, also es ist toll, dass dieser Mann da ist, dass er all diese guten Intuitionen hat und dass er sich einfach auskennt, damit wie man eine gute Geschichte erzählt, aber das alles hätte nicht stattgefunden und darauf wird es leider runtergebrochen ohne Kohle. Also wenn ich Steve Jobs nicht damals da gesessen und gesagt hätte, Pixar, da glaube ich dran und da Millionen reingesteckt hätte und gesagt hätte, egal was sie machen, ich will, dass das stattfindet und dann haben die halt diese tollen Leute bezahlen können, die dann einfach Toy Story gemacht haben und gezeigt haben, okay, CGI animiert, der Punkt ist ja, viele Leute sehen computeranimierte Filme und denken, ah ja, deswegen ist das erfolgreich, computeranimiert, sieht, sieht halt aus wie 2015. Nein, die können einfach geile Geschichten erzählen, die haben Figuren mit Tiefe, denen man glaubt, denen man das Gefühl hat, ich weiss, was der will, wo der hin möchte, was der erzählen möchte. Und dann ist es auch noch witzig, es ist einfach, die machen geile Dramödien. Ja, Steve Jobs Funfact steht ja im Guinness-Buch der Rekorde für das geringste Gehalt aller Zeiten. Der hat sich selber ein Gehalt von einem Dollar im Jahr ausgezahlt, damit eben Pixar wahnsinnig viel Geld, mehr Geld hat und diese Firma aufblühen kann. Aber ganz kurz, was ich noch sagen wollte, basiert es nicht letztendlich auch auf einer gewissen Arroganz oder einem gewissen, Arroganz vielleicht ist das falsche Wort, aber einem Ernstnehmen des Publikums zu sagen, wir können dem Publikum was zutrauen. Und da möchte ich gerne die Schleife zu Luke Mockit schlagen, weil der natürlich auch immer sagt, so von wegen, ah, das Publikum muss es verstehen, es muss nahbar sein, es muss ein Wir-Gefühl geben, man muss es irgendwie, jeder im Publikum soll es verstehen müssen. Und ist nicht das auch gerade so ein bisschen der Gedankengang, so dieses, ja, wir müssen für die Masse und wir brauchen Themen, die aus dem Alltag gegriffen sind und Mann und Frau und hier und da und Autofahren und Ikea, das müssen Themen sind, ach die Leute, die wollen gar nicht nachdenken, die wollen einfach nur aus der Couch sitzen.
Sind das nicht auch die Gedankengänge, die letztendlich dazu führen, dass einem dann halt so ein Rick and Morty-Skript um die Ohren gehauen wird, so von wegen von, hä, du hast hier eine dreiebenige Realitätssimulation, aus der sie versuchen auszubrechen, so what, das hat mit dem Leben der Menschen nichts zu tun. ist da nicht bei den Amerikanern eher eine Arroganz da zu sagen, so nee, das ist einfach geil so.
Und dass man dann auch im Wechselspiel eine Zuschauerschaft heranerzieht, die dann auch Bock drauf hat und die sowas dann auch annimmt. Ja, das war ja ein Prozess. Also das war ja nicht mit einmal da, dass so ein kranker Scheiss da gewesen ist. Aber der Prozess kann ja nur angestossen werden, wenn mal jemand sagt, fuck it, wir machen das jetzt einfach so und nehmen einfach mal eine Scheissquote drauf oder einen Flop oder irgendwas. Aber dafür existiert eben eine Industrie in den USA und die existiert hier nun mal nicht und da muss man sagen da ist in deutschland noch das öffentlich-rechtliche fernsehen am nächsten dran weil aber die einfach gelten die hand nehmen müssen um dinge auszuprobieren ihr habt recht ihr macht es hier wir machen es ja wir sind verdammte visionäre wir sind genies ich finde unglaublich dass so eine aber da geht noch mehr verdammt noch mal wir können uns jetzt hier nicht auf die schulde ankommen nein aber nehmt das. Also das Ding ist ja auch, dass ich, also ich habe ja noch, ich will natürlich auch irgendwann eineinhalb Stünder machen und habe auch drei Ansätze im Kopf, von denen ich aber noch nicht war. Einer davon sogar einen Spielfilm, das wäre ja gar keine Animation. Und das könnte vielleicht sogar der erste sein, weil der dann sich noch relativ kostengünstig umsetzen lässt. Du kannst ja einen, gut, naja jetzt nicht Kartoffelsalat, aber du kannst natürlich einen Spielfilm grundsätzlich drehen für ein, zwei Millionen. Das geht. Animationsfilm ist ein... Kartoffelsalat war 400.000, war das Budget. 400.000 Euro. Ich habe irgendwas von knapp unter der Million gehört. Naja, wie auch immer. Jedenfalls Kohle ist da leider immer mit ein Problem und da muss man erst mal drankommen. Aber ich mache es eben anders. Ich versuche mir erst mal mit kleinen möglichkeiten und das mache ich jetzt eben seit mittlerweile auch acht neun jahren eben auf youtube-videos zu produzieren von denen ich denke das geht schon in die richtung wie ich finde dass man humor auch erzählen kann und wie er im deutschen fernsehen so definitiv nicht stattfindet jedenfalls nicht aus deutschland produziert und was ich nicht ahnen konnte aber hat mir jetzt ein einigermaßen großes publikum dadurch dass ich hoffentlich da mitnehmen kann, wenn es darum geht, einen Kinofilm zu machen. Aber ich habe das abseits vom Fernsehen gemacht und abseits vom Kino und die Zeit braucht es in Deutschland eben einfach. Aber das könnt ihr auch machen und wir, oh Gott, wir erzeugen gerade dieses Gemeinschaftsgefühl, aber wenn ihr wirklich Bock habt, ich wäre sofort dabei zu sagen, Leute, lasst uns mal Ideen zusammenschmeissen und gucken, was uns da einfällt. Und mit eurer Kreativität und meinem Input und allem, was man zusammenschmeissen kann. Joscha Sauerbecht, der dafür ist. Joscha, er ist Joscha, er muss erst mal sein eigenes Ding machen, weil auch Joscha und ich haben schon zusammen Skripte entwickelt. Und ich habe ja sogar auch mal ein Drehbuch für die Nicht-Lustig-Serie geschrieben. Also wir haben schon viel zusammengearbeitet und können das auch gut. Aber er muss jetzt erst mal seine eigene Serie an den Punkt bringen und dann macht er was anderes. Das heisst natürlich auch an euch Hörer da draußen, spenden, spenden, spenden, wir brauchen eine Menge Booster, das muss... Wir haben tatsächlich noch eine Hörspiel-Storyline offen von zwei Leuten, die im Zoo Eis kaufen. Die Storyline ist noch offen, die muss noch fortgeführt werden. Die hat sehr gut angefangen, sehr viel Verspannung angefangen. Du hast mich beeindruckt. Die Leute haben es geliebt. Ralf Rute, vielen Dank, dass du da warst. Ich war uns ganz toll. Vielen Dank, ihr seid so schöne Menschen. Denk noch mal drüber nach, ob du vielleicht noch irgendwie sowas mit Malerat. Also mal gucken, in der Sparkasse, wenn du da noch jemanden kennst, schau einfach mal, ob du da irgendwie guckst. Kann nicht schaden, oder?
Ja, vielen Dank.
Ralf Rudel, meine Damen und Herren. Stefan Titschler, meine Damen und Herren.
Ralf Rudel, das war das Podcast-Suppe und wir heben ab.